la chambre haute a commencé l'examen de
ce projet de loi vers 14h30 vers 18
heures les sénateurs ont ensuite entamé
l'examen de l'article 1 vous savez qui
transforme le pass sanitaire en passe
vaccinale la séance va reprendre dans
quelques minutes le temps d'évoquer les
modifications voulues par le sénat on
l'a vu déjà dans ces débats une majorité
de sénateurs devraient voter en faveur
du principe de ce pass vaccinale il dit
ainsi vouloir être responsable mais avec
des modifications et vous les voyez le
sénat veut un pass vaccinale avec un
seuil de dix mille hospitalisation et
aussi avec et bien un taux de
vaccination de 80% dans les départements
et le pass vaccinale serait réservée
uniquement aux plus de 18 ans et pas
pour les 12 17 ans pour évoquer toutes
ces informations je suis ici en salle
des conférences avec patrick kanner
bonsoir messieurs qu'anna que j'ai calmé
président du groupe socialiste ici au
sénat on l'a compris une majorité va se
dessiner y compris avec votre groupe les
socialistes pour voter en faveur de ce
texte dans sa version du sénat avec des
seuils c'est bien cela oui nous avons
quand même des lignes rouges que nous ne
voulons pas voir dépassée
disons le clairement je pense évidemment
aux contrôles d'identité
nous ne sommes pas du tout favorables
même avec la carte de piscine ou la
carte vitale avec une photo pour être
clair que de permettre finalement un
restaurateur de contrôler le pass
vaccinale et le contrôle d'identité donc
nous avons encore des exigences avant de
vous assurer de notre vote mais qui
devrait être favorable parce que le pass
vaccinale finalement concours à l'aube
lives obligation vaccinale que nous
avons à nouveau un l'accablement défendu
avant même l'article 1er on l'a entendu
effectivement tout à l'heure c'était
juste après la discussion générale et
par un vote 73 voix pour seulement et
plus de 250 voix contre le sénat a à
nouveau refusé cette obligation
vaccinale pourquoi est ce que vous dites
que c'est la clé de voûte de ce pass
vaccinale je crois que tout le monde
reconnaît qu' aujourd'hui la vaccination
n'empêche pas d'avoir malheureusement le
variant notamment au micron mais empêche
d'avoir des formes graves monsieur véran
a raison de dire que quand on est
vacciné quand on a un schéma vaccinal
complet on a vingt fois moins de chances
de présenter les formes graves et donc
d'être hospitalisé et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que ils ce sont
essentiellement des non vaccinés qui
occupent les lits de réanimation ou de
soin intensif moralité puisque tout le
monde dans la vaccination est bien
allons-y faisant tomber les masques je
le garde à ce stade les faisant tomber
les masques la vaccination obligatoire
elle est capable d'être entendu par la
majorité des français oui lui il dit que
c'est impossible à contrôler il donne
l'exemple des onze vaccins obligatoires
qui existe déjà et qui sont contrôlés à
l'entrée à l'école il dit il n'y aura
pas la possibilité de le faire avec
cette nouvelle obligation qu'est ce que
vous lui répondre je lui réponds entendu
cet argument si je lui réponds qu on est
en train de créer une obligation sans
contrôle ou un contrôle sans
l'obligation fait en tout cas plus
personne n'y comprend rien je vous le
dis comme je le pense et que on le voit
bien d'ailleurs sur la cacophonie dans
dans les écoles jeudi les enseignants
seront des dizaines de milliers à
défiler contre une forme de finalement
de d'inertie mais d'inertie coupable du
gouvernement en la matière par rapport
aux tests qui devraient pratiquer dans
les écoles depuis tant de temps deux
mois donc moi je dis simplement il faut
clarifier il faut faciliter la vie des
français et l'égalité vaccinale au
travers de l'obligation vaccinale
universel serait la meilleure solution
donc nous avons été battus une nouvelle
fois ce soir et je peux vous dire que
pendant la pause j'ai eu des sénateurs
et l'air dont je tairai le nom qui m'ont
dit mais finalement c'est vous qui avez
raison parce que ce serait tellement
plus simple mais ils ont respecté la
discipline de groupe selon la formule
consacrée on voit il reste encore plus
de 160 amendements mais on voit le le
sénat va modifier le texte de façon
l'encadré
bon vous allez vous allez encadrer le
lepad vaccinale ça va faire une
différence entre les deux textes celui
de l'assemblée nationale et celui du
sénat d'avoir une commission mixte
paritaire qui va être réunies donc avec
sept députés sept sénateurs pour tenter
de trouver un compromis est ce que vous
pensez ce compromis atteignable il est
atteignable si le gouvernement fait des
efforts je crois qu'il a intérêt à en
faire il veut aller vite savez regardons
bien l'agenda aller vite c'est adopter
le texte allez pour le 15 janvier grosso
modo peut-être un recours au conseil
constitutionnel nous verrons bien est ce
que vous le ferez n'ont à priori sauf si
le texte ne nous va pas du tout mais on
espère quand même que nous allons
obtenir quelques gains d'amendements
permettez moi l'équivalent faire
également je pense que les élèves vont
pas faire un recours contre un texte
qu'ils auraient amélioré chez eux et
surtout c'est la cmp est conclusive je
rentre pas dans les détails du
fonctionnement de nos institutions ne
pas y avoir de recours au conseil
constitutionnel oui moi je crois qu'il
n'y aura pas de recours aux conséquences
qu elle en tout cas vu du sénat à partir
de là le texte sera promulgué en tout
début de semaine prochaine peut-être
même pendant le week-end prochain mais
pour qu'il soit réellement efficace
réellement efficace il faudra que les
non vaccinés qui sont visés par les
mesures d'intimidation de fait et bien
se vaccine une fois deux fois trois fois
et donc l'applicabilité réel ce texte
n'interviendra que fin février on a
perdu six mois plus de huit mois pour
atteindre l'immunité collective
potentiel vous le pensez c'est pas ce
texte qui va pouvoir répondre par
exemple à l'urgence sur la vague numéro
5 ou non en russie ce qu'ils sont en
train de nous si ce n'est pas un texte
de santé publique c'est un texte
politique un texte politique on l'a bien
vu avec l'intimidation fait par le
président de la république qui a jeté de
l'huile sur le feu en plein débat à
l'assemblée nationale ça vous montre
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un contexte
politique qui est très liée aux
élections je le regrette parce que c'est
la santé des français qui est pourtant
en cause un dernier mot sur cette cmp 1
sur cette entente possible ou pas avec
les députés quelles sont les lignes
rouges que vous vous fixez votre groupe
politique vous parliez par exemple du
contrôle d'identité sans etienne c'est
une ligne rouge effectivement nous ne
voulons pas que quelqu'un de non
habilitées puisse contrôler l'identité
d'un autre français déjà les français
contrôle l'autre moitié des français et
réciproquement il faut en rester là ce
sera le sens de les amendements très
bien et bien écoutez je vais vous
libérer puisque la cloche je vient de
retentir d'un instant à l'autre la
séance devrait reprendre puisque vous
voyez la présidente laurence rossignol
présidente socialiste de jeter revenir
là allez-y je vous en prie messieurs
caméra vient de s'installer
effectivement au plateau et que la
science est reprise direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre cette séance
publique scénarii mobilisés toute la
nuit toute la soirée pour suivre ce
texte modifiant le code de la santé
publique dans l'édition des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement 75
de l'article 1 on y va tout le monde est
prêt
bon
alors à l'article 1er d'abord un
amendement
monsieur kaner
les présidents quelques secondes un
présidente j'étais bloqué par public
sénat donc c'est pour une bonne cause
pour vous signaler que sur le scrutin 70
scrutin public 70 concernant
l'amendement 33 rectifié monsieur
maurice antiste souhaitait ne pas
participer au vote
merci monsieur le président actes et
donnez votre mise au point qui sera
publié au journal officiel
on continue avec l'article l'amendement
qui le présente monsieur soeur
dames la présidente monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
la situation
se tend beaucoup dans les établissements
scolaires en ce début d'année en raison
du variant au micro qui fait grimper le
nombre de contaminations à niveau encore
jamais atteint
les cannoises positifs se multiplient
dans les écoles et le nombre de
fermetures de classes commencent à
augmenter
il nous paraît absolument impératif de
limiter au maximum la circulation du
virus en milieu scolaire
le pressentent amendement permet de
donner au premier ministre la faculté
d'instaurer la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique de dépistage régulière avec
des campagnes de tests salivaires dans
les écoles et la distribution d'autotest
pour les collégiens c'est pourquoi je
rectifie cet amendement madame la
présidente car il est écrit les autorise
à eux les écoles collèges et lycées nous
entendons que cet amendement ne
s'applique qu'aux écoles et collèges non
pas au lycée voyez vous c'est une
rectification c'est une erreur on
s'était mis d'accord là dessus donc cet
amendement reprend l'une des
préconisations du rapport de la mission
commune d'information
destiné à évaluer les effets des mesures
prises ou envisagées en matière de
finement ou de vos restriction
d'activité relatifs à la stratégie
vaccinale à mettre en oeuvre pour
limiter la quatrième vague de pandémie
et que notre collègue bernard jomier a
déposé le 1er juillet dernier
je dirais simplement dans le temps qu'il
me reste que chacun voit mes chers
collègues que l'anarchie
n'ayons pas peur du mot dans lequel nous
sommes dans les établissements scolaires
les ordres contre-ordre les changements
de stratégie du ministre d'un jour à
l'autre d'une semaine à l'autre
aboutissent à une situation inextricable
s'il est très difficile madame la
présidente
pour les parents comme pour les
enseignants mais c'est pourquoi vous
comprendrez l'importance mais de cet
amendement mais c'est sûr vous défier la
présidence
à quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur rapporteur
madame la présidente à mon grand regret
je vais m compte tenu de la qualité des
auteurs de cet amendement est de
l'intervention de jean pierre sueur je
vais mettre un avis favorable au nom de
la commission
cher président sûr vous avez vu que le
plus grand désordre règne à l'école que
des dispositions sont prises la veille
pour le lendemain puis annulé par le
premier ministre qui en décident
d'autres et voilà que vous proposez un
autre système je crois que un mouvement
de protestation est en train de gonfler
à l'école de la république
les professeurs devraient être nombreux
à se mettre en grève jeudi prochain les
parents d'élèves pour beaucoup d'entre
eux les soutiennent je ne voudrais pas
que nous ajoutions à la confusion
d'autant plus que
le
régime de gestion de la crise sanitaire
permet déjà de faire ce que vous
proposez je ne tiens pas à ce que nouri
j-10 fion davantage une situation qui a
fait la preuve de sa complexité
d'ailleurs bien prévisible le conseil
scientifique ayant lui même dès le mois
de décembre annoncé qu' on allait au
devant d'une désorganisation sociétal
majeur et bien nous y sommes et l'avis
du gouvernement gouvernement préfère
relever
relevé que la france est le pays où
l'école est restée la plus ouverte au
monde monsieur le rapporteur et je pense
qu'il faut s'en réjouir n'est ce pas
plutôt que de se réjouir d'une mouvement
social qui aura lieu qui aura lieu jeudi
et je suis convaincu je suis convaincu
tous les pleurer mais écoutez je suis
ravi que vous le déplorez tout le monde
je pense que les parents d'élèves les
professionnels de l'éducation de la
communauté éducative comme on dit qui
comprend les parents d'élèves ont été
rassurés notamment par les annonces qui
ont été faites par le premier ministre
hier pour simplifier mais pour
simplifier pour simplifier pour
simplifier la façon dont se déroulent
les tests notamment pour les élèves qui
sont quand quelqu'un contacter qui je
vous le rappelle permettent quand même
que nos enfants puissent continuer à
aller à l'école a bénéficié la
continuité éducative continuer à aller
voir leurs petits camarades et avoir des
relations sociales avec lui on sait à
quel point c'est important on sait à
quel point cette crise a eu des effets
délétères sur la santé mentale de nos
enfants donc je me réjouis plutôt de
cela est effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit
dispositions actuelles permettent d'ores
et déjà au premier ministre de prendre
des mesures pour s'adapter au plus près
l'évolution de la situation ou à la
réalité de la situation de nos
concitoyens comme le premier ministre
l'a fait encore hier un avis défavorable
monsieur juillet pour une explication de
vote
merci madame la présidente je crois que
ce soir nos ministres ont décidé de ne
pas écouter réellement ce qu'on dit le
ministre nous n'avons jamais dit qu'il
fallait fermer les écoles mais nous
avons bien noté
la communication du gouvernement et
encore hier à propos du nouveau
protocole la communication du ministère
ces objectifs gardez les écoles ouvertes
et nous nous disons garder des écoles
ouvertes mais il y assurer la sécurité
sanitaire des enfants et des personnels
et c'est ça que vous refusez de faire
avec je dois dire une constance
remarquable depuis le début malgré
l'avis de notre mission d'information et
nora porter sur la mise en place d'un
dépistage salivaire dans les écoles
malgré l'avis du conseil scientifique du
mois d'août sur la question répétée en
décembre et encore une fois en décembre
les alertes n'ont pas manqué pour dire
attention le virus flambent il faut
mettre en place une procédure de
dépistage plus opérantes et à la rentrée
de janvier que vous avez refusé et de
décaler et doux et également on dit
instituer un protocole efficace est
arrivé ce qui doit arriver c'est le
chaos dans les écoles et moi je pense
que le ministre de l'éducation se
devrait se poser des questions sur la
façon dont il assume ses responsabilités
et je voudrais dire aux rapporteurs cher
rapporteur que ce n'est pas un nouveau
système le dépistage que nous proposons
c'est encore une fois celui que le
conseil scientifique propose c'est une
méthode qui est prouvée alors certes je
reconnais que ça nécessite une
organisation et je n'ai pas d'illusions
sur la capacité à la mettre en place
mais monsieur le rapporteur c'est pas
parce que le gouvernement est incapable
de mettre en place cette organisation
que nous parlementaires nous ne devons
pas demander si nous pensons qu'elle est
nécessaire qu'ils le fassent et c'est
l'objet de cet amendement c'est de dire
que le cas où a assez duré et que le
chaos va continuer avec ces protocoles
qui change tous les deux jours et un
gouvernement qui reste sur la même ligne
il ne cherche pas à réduire le risque
sanitaire à l'école madame benbassa
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente
monsieur juillet a dit l'essentiel mais
je voudrais ajouter que dans ses
consignes sanitaires dans ce protocole
sanitaire on n'a pas pris
la mesure de de ce que cela coûte aux
enseignants aux administrateurs des
écoles et à tout ce personnel qui
travaille dans des conditions
excellentes et on leur ajoute du travail
au travail qu'ils ont déjà alors écoutez
on ne peut pas faire passer des
protocoles sanitaires sans prendre en
considération
l'écosystème de l'école il ne suffit pas
de penser à la santé des élèves il faut
aussi penser aux parents aux difficultés
que ce protocole créé auprès des parents
et aussi aux enseignants et à tout le
personnel et scolaire je vous remercie
madame huguette elle
merci madame la présidente je suivrai
sur cet amendement la vie de notre à
porter toutefois je voudrais profiter de
cette occasion pour parler des tests
notamment dans les écoles on a deux
types de problèmes l'un qui est évoqué
et qui fait l'unanimité c'est
aujourd'hui extrêmement compliquée voire
impossible à réaliser quand on puisse
les parents ou un enfant dans une place
un enfant dans une autre je transmettrai
monsieur le ministre le mail que j'ai
reçu d'une femme air qui m'expliquait
quelque chose qui aurait pu être un
sketch mais qui je crois une réalité et
elle s'est elle même retrouvée à assurer
la cantine d'enceinte dans son école qui
ce que la deuxième est elle même prise à
devoir faire des je pense que il est
nécessaire alors l'école est restée
ouverte et c'est très bien il est
nécessaire que tout s'apaise et que ce
soit plus visée parce qu'il ya un
désordre dans l'école il ya un désordre
dans la famille est un désordre dans
l'entreprise et vous le savez les gens
sont fatigués il faut qu'on essaie
d'assainir sain et moi je voudrais
évoquer le sujet et on a parlé un peu
monsieur jo ni avec les tests salivaires
je pense très sincèrement que pour des
enfants les tests salivaires sont plus
aisés à faire et qu'il semble qu'une
étude scientifique en décembre et
indiqué que les tests salivaires sur
lesquels il y avait des réserves pour
les variants précédent était tout à fait
largement acceptable pour le varian qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui donc monsieur le
ministre
allez vous encourager développer
facilité des tests salivaires dans les
écoles et je parle des maternelles et
notamment des primaires je vous remercie
monsieur opère
la présidente monsieur le ministre
collègues je serais d'accord avec le
président soeur qui dit que l'école est
en chantier c'est vrai que c'est le
chantier à l'école ce chantier parce que
parce que tous les jours il ya des
directives des mails de monsieur blanc
caire
les enseignantes s'y retrouve plus
vous avez dit que le virus flambe mais
c'est une mascarade on teste tout le
monde on fait des tests partout un
million cinq cent mille tests par jour
ça coûte un milliard par mois et avec ça
on construit trois hôpitaux neufs et
quatre écoles donc à force de tester
c'est sûr qu'on va des pistes et plein
de choses des gens qui ne sont jamais
malades des enfants qui ne sont jamais
malades et ce sont les parents qui
souffrent les parents qui souffle qui
emmènent leurs enfants le matin l'école
et qui reçoivent un mail ou un sms une
demi heure après comme quoi il faut
qu'il revient de chercher leurs enfants
alors qu'ils sont déjà au travail voilà
donc je pense qu'il faudrait sortir de
cette mascarade monsieur le ministre
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 75 briques madama sait si
pardon
président il faut savoir regarder à
gauche mme adama président
c'était une boutade à une boutade
nous voterons cet amendement déposé par
deux collègues socialistes parce
qu'effectivement
les eaux les enseignants sont à bout
les parents sont à bout en deux bourgs
et bien évidemment les enfants aussi
sont à bout et je pense que la
préconisation qui est fait avec cet
amendement va tout à fait dans le bon
sens et j'aimerais à l'instar de ce que
vient de dire bagatelle monsieur le
ministre comprendre les raisons qui font
que les gamins qui sont notamment en
maternelle ne puissent pas bénéficier
des tests salivaires dont on a parlé
tout au début de la crise de la colline
et qui aujourd'hui a disparu des radars
ça me semble une une solution
acceptable pour les enfants de moins qui
sont en maternelle dont donc de moins de
2 5 ans et par ailleurs je pense
qu'effectivement
c'est une de nos propositions qu'il
faudrait
que la la la elle l'a la communauté
nationale prenne en charge une campagne
de dépistage dans les écoles
élémentaires et maternelles viennent
parler des tests salivaires élémentaire
aidants et dans les collèges donc c'est
une un amendement de bon sens me
semble-t-il qui errait tout à fait dans
le sens d'une meilleure
comment dire
appréciation de la circulation du virus
dans les écoles et dans les écoles et
qui tendrait effectivement à rassurer à
la fois la communauté scolaire les
parents d'élèves et les élèves bien
évidemment donc nous voterons en faveur
de cet amendement
bien nous pouvons passer au vote je vais
donc mettre aux voix la demande dans 75
rectifié rectifiant ce quine son chant
est restreint ne comporte plus les
lycées c'est une rectification faite par
l'auteur d'un double avis défavorable
pied pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas qu'ils option n'est pas
adopté
nous avons maintenant deux amendements
destitution commune l'amendement 18
madame co m oui merci madame la
présidente cet abandon de repli vise à
supprimer les alinéas instaurant
précisément impasse vaccinale nous
saluons les efforts une fois de plus de
la commission des lois quant à la
recherche d'un compromis moins néfaste
pour la sauvegarde de nos libertés
publiques dans des temps de crise
sanitaire qui plonge le pays dans un
état d'exception depuis près de deux ans
mais mes chers collègues le dispositif
proposé révèle hélas de nombreuses
faiblesses d'abord vous nous expliquer
qu'il s'agit là d' apporter un caractère
temporaire à ces nouvelles restrictions
de liberté puisque vous conditionner
leur usage à la fois un critère de
fréquentation des services hospitaliers
et à un critère de couverture vaccinale
sur la première condition nous avons
tendance à dire qu en quelque sorte il
fait le jeu du gouvernement qui vient
légiférer de manière
intempestive pour pallier les carences
du système hospitalier dont il est
lui-même à l'origine notamment avec les
fermetures de lits je rappelle qu'il ya
eu cinq mille 700 lits qui ont été
fermées en pleine pandémie et le manque
de personnel pour justifier une telle
mesure ne convient absolument pas ne
tient pas car il existe des solutions
pour redonner à ces professions du soin
tout leur attractivité
quant à la couverture vaccinale de 80%
de la population qui bénéficie d'un
schéma vaccinal complet comment cela se
limitera dans le temps puisque ce schéma
vaccinal semble amené à fluctuer au fil
des mutations du virus alors
effectivement on peut espérer avec les
plus optimistes que le variant omicron
soit le dernier mais bon c'est
absolument de loin d'être certain vous
voyez que tout cela est très
hypothétique et vous le savez sans doute
mieux que nous l'effort dialectique est
donc considérable mais ne nous convainc
absolument pas il ya pas de 2,2
d'arguments pour nous convaincre du
caractère attentatoire aux libertés
publiques portent une nouvelle fois ces
mesures alors même à l'heure même où là
défenseur des droits alerte sur la
restriction des libertés individuelles
je vous remercie merci madame noël pour
le 54 rectifié bits
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet alinéa
conditionne l'accès à certains
établissements à la détention d'un
justificatif de statut vaccinal malgré
les nombreuses promesses du gouvernement
de ne jamais recourir à un tel
dispositif cette exclusion assumé du
gouvernement à l'égard des citoyens non
vaccinés est inacceptable en instaurant
un pass vaccinale le gouvernement
entrave les libertés les plus
fondamentales en instaurant un outil de
discipline à la gare de n'importe quel
citoyen en fonction de son statut
vaccinal le pass vaccinale constitue une
triple hypocrisie premièrement dans la
mesure où la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire le choix d'une partie de nos
concitoyens de ne pas y recourir ne peut
entraîner pour eux une quelconque forme
de déchéance de citoyenneté on ne peut
pas les sanctionner pour un choix qui ne
constitue pas un délit sur ce sujet
comme sur bien d'autres le en même temps
vaccinale est un échec et une
escroquerie il se traduit par la
négation de toutes les valeurs de notre
république
seconde hypocrisie mes chers collègues
faut-il le rappeler plus on a besoin du
vaccin et moi on a besoin du pass
vaccinale nous avons maintenant une
connaissance plus fine de ce virus ce
sont les sujets âgés ou atteints de
comorbidité qui développe les formes les
plus graves la mortalité faible en
dessous de 50 ans augmente
progressivement chez les sujets âgés de
plus de 65 ans qui représentent plus de
80% des décès or croyez vous vraiment
que la mise en oeuvre d'un quelconque
passe vaccinale à l'entrée des
discothèques des parcs d'attraction des
piscines des bibliothèques ou des bars
poussera ses sujets fragiles à la
vaccination absolument pas enfin s'il
s'agit de combattre l'épidémie et la
propagation du virus la présentation
d'un test négatif se révélera bien plus
efficace que de se prévaloir d'un vaccin
qui n'empêchent ni d'être contaminés ni
d'autres contaminants je vous propose
donc à travers cet amendement de vous
opposer à ce dispositif de passes
vaccinale qui est inefficace et injuste
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis sur
ces deux amendements
défavorable pour les deux amendements je
signale à leurs auteurs
qu'en supprimant la disposition qui crée
le pass vaccinale ils n'obtiennent qu'un
résultat faire revivre le passé
sanitaires je salue donc parce que je
suppose que c'est conscient leur
évolution il était contre le pass
sanitaire maintenant ils sont tour
peut-être que dans trois mois ils seront
également pour le pass vaccinale
métier de ministre mais c'est un avis
défavorable à la présidente ces deux
amendements au tir elle a supprimé le
lepad rex je suis ouvert pour une
explication de vote
madame la présidente monsieur michel
collègues à suivre rassurez vous
monsieur rapporta nous sommes contre le
fast vaccinale et nous sommes contre le
pass sanitaires
je je
je vienne chose que je regrette j'avais
présenté un amendement pour que si on
instaure un pass vaccinale qui ne dit
pas que la vaccination est obligatoire
j'avais demandé à ce que en cas d'effets
secondaires on puisse indemniser les
gens qui ont des effets secondaires par
l'oniam comme on l'a fait lors de la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants ou
tous les soignants comme moi si nous
avons des les effets secondaires sont
pris en charge par l'oniam donc je pense
qu'il ya une rupture d'égalité entre les
soignants et les gens qui seront obligés
de se vacciner sans que le mot
obligatoire existent et qu'ils auront
des effets secondaires d'un à 177 milles
au 3 octobre dans 24% de grave merci
merci je regarde à gauche à regard
d'autres fendues regarde à droite qu'à
plus d'explications de vote donc je vais
mettre aux voix ces deux amendements qui
ont reçu un double avis défavorable 18
pieds pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté de 54 qui est pour et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté monsieur
le ministre vous à la parole pour
l'amendement 200
merci madame là la présidente à
l'amendement effectivement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qui vise à
rétablir certaines modalités
d'application du pass vaccinale
que je vais me permettre de vous
détailler brièvement
et ce dans leur version adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture pour certains d'entre eux en
tout cas et en particulier en ce qui
concerne l'encadrement général son
application aux mineurs ainsi que le
recours aux passes sanitaires pour les
réunions politiques
le gouvernement partage la volonté du
sénat d'encadrer de la manière la plus
équilibrée possible la mise en oeuvre de
ces outils nécessaires à la lutte contre
l'épidémie et je pense que les
évolutions du projet de loi à ce stade
peut en témoigner néanmoins j'ai déjà
dit nous avons commencé à avoir ce débat
avant la suspension il n'est pas
souhaitable selon nous de fixer dans la
loi des critères chiffrés pour appliquer
le pass vaccinale car je pense que
l'actualité nous là nous l'a montré nous
le montre encore jour après jour des
records le contamination sont battus
excusez moi l'expression chaque jour qui
passe l'épidémie change de nature
régulièrement cela aussi l'histoire
depuis deux ans nous là nous l'a montré
et nous devons disposer de la réactivité
nécessaire à la lutte contre l'épidémie
je pense que c'est un des enseignements
et toute l'humilité que nous avons dit
que nous devons adopter
désormais après les deux années non je
pense que c'est un principe qui nous a
pas mal le guider les uns et les autres
monsieur le rapporteur depuis deux ans
de même la question de la
territorialisation des mesures se heurte
aux nécessaires déplacement des
personnes entre départements
problématique nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de débattre en ses murs que
le projet de loi vise précisément à
pouvoir sanctuariser le pass vaccinale
et vous le savez l'alternative la plus à
même de nous prémunir de restrictions
plus importante encore des libertés pour
ces raisons le gouvernement estime que
l'encadrement du recours au pass
vaccinale est poussé à son maximum dans
la version qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale et à laquelle je
vous propose donc par sadate amendement
de revenir pour les mêmes raisons le
recours aux passes sanitaires cette fois
ci au pass sanitaires non pas au pass
vaccinale pour la tenue des réunions
politiques ne peut être conditionnée à
de tels critères stricts et rigide qui
ne permettent pas une adaptation rapide
des moyens de lutte contre l'épidémie je
pense que là dessus vous serez d'accord
pour me rejoindre en particulier et
enfin le gouvernement estime que le
dispositif adopté par l'assemblée
nationale à la la quasi unanimité je
vous le rappelle je crois qu'il manquait
de voir sauf erreur opère une
conciliation équilibré s'agissant des
mineurs qu'ils méritent en effet une
attention particulière bien placé
peut-être pour défendre ce point de vue
entre la nécessité de garantir un accès
à des activités indispensables à leur
développement
d'une part comme les sorties scolaires
ou les activités périscolaires et
extrascolaires et celle d'instituts et
d'autre part un dispositif de passes
vaccinale qui soit suffisamment homogène
et protecteur pour leur santé l'objet du
présent amendement est donc sur ce point
et sur ces trois points de rétablir la
version du projet de loi qui a été
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la commission défavorable merci
je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 200 du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 182e monsieur richard
que nous propose notre rapporteur et qui
a été soutenue par la commission
consiste à créer un automatisme de
disparition de la réglementation du pass
vaccinale en fonction du franchissement
de certains chiffres de l'évolution de
la pandémie c'est un système
d'automatiser des automatismes qui est
incomplet
puisque on prêt on prétend par la loi
crée une abrogation immédiate de décret
qui comporte des dispositions assez
nombreuse sur simplement la base de
l'arrivée d'un chiffre
il est par exemple le taux d'incidence
dans un département où le nombre de
spitz alizés au niveau national qui
constate ce chiffre comment est-il
vérifier quelle est la date de
d'obligations d'abroger le décret qui en
est la responsabilité rien de cela n'est
prévu
le système est anormalement rigide
puisque au terme de ces dispositifs si
on a neuf mille neuf cents personnes
hospitalisées pour qu vide on ne peut
plus appliquer la réglementation
nationalement et suivi jours après on
remonte à dix mille cent personnes
infectées à l'hôpital il faut tout
rétablir donc c'est évidemment pas du
tout fonctionnel et enfin l'amendement
créer une mosaïque une mosaïque
totalement irréaliste en voulant
appliquer le décret sur le pass and it
sur le pass vaccinale dans un
département lorsqu il y à une proportion
de
deux d'apparition du virus au dessus
d'un certain chiffre est de faire
disparaître le décret quand on parle de
chiffres donc tous les éléments de la
vie quotidienne de l'aude et de nos
compatriotes qui les amène à se déplacer
d'un département dans l'autre sont
évidemment perturbé donc il me sens
vraiment que ça a été trop artificielle
et que c'est un objectif politique de
manifester une différence avec le
gouvernement mais il vaut beaucoup mieux
constate concerne peut conserver la
méthode réaliste que leur apportera
défendu par exemple à propos de la
capacité
et donc de s'en tenir aux textes actuels
qui prévoit la disparition d'autres
jolis prix nécessaire madame décidera
pour l'amendement sera rectifiée
l'article 1er du présent projet de loi
vise évidemment à transformer le pass
and i ter en passe vaccinale plus
restrictif que le premier lors des
débats en commission des lois un
amendement du rapporteur a permis de
définir des critères d'extinction de ce
dispositif
toutefois le présente amendements que
proposait et de simplifier ses critères
et de fonds dès l'extinction du pass
vaccinale sur le taux de déprogrammation
des opérations le taux de 30% qui vous
est proposé de déprogrammation retenu
correspond au second stade sur 4 définit
par l'assistance publique des hôpitaux
de paris permettant de se fonder sur un
critère objectif tout en protégeant les
soins orco vide qui sont aussi des
victimes collatérales de cette pandémie
merci monsieur chanterelle pour le 77
rectifier
oui merci madame la présidente cet
amendement est très simple et il repose
en fait en lien avec l'argumentation du
gouvernement depuis le début de cette
pandémie qui fait en fait qui justifie
toutes les mesures le pass vaccinale et
mesure d'exception qui sont prises
depuis le début par l'engorgement que
dis-je la saturation de nos hôpitaux
c'est votre point central un petit
rappel au passage l'engorgement la
situation nos services hospitaliers vous
en êtes également vous en avez une
grande part en grande partie parce que
je rappelle quand même que depuis 2010
est vous avez supprimé de nombreux lits
vous avez continué même en pleine
pandémie est donc ce critère basé sur le
nombre
d'hospitalisations moi je pense en
regardant clairement les choses il est
très important à nos compatriotes de
donner une issue de sortie il faut
donner des critères précis qui ont été
analysés en fonction des vagues et c'est
pas dix mille c'est à partir de douze
mille et sur une durée de 7 jours parce
que si vous faites 10 mille une journée
lendemain ça remonte ça redescend enfin
ce n'est pas pierre faut prendre sur une
période donc quand on regarde les
périodes de sept jours à partir de 12000
vous êtes dans une vague à 10000 par
exemple si vous prenez ce qui a été mis
dans le texte est sorti de la commission
par monsieur le rapporteur à 10000 ou
par exemple au mois d'août il ya eu
pendant deux semaines onze mille donc en
fait vous aurez remet il passe juste
pour deux semaines vous l'auriez enlever
c'est pas possible il faut des sorties
de ces de ces mesures des sexes
d'exception claire précise et qui
permettent d'en sortir réellement à
partir du moment où vous entraîner nos
compatriotes en donnant un objectif
clair de sortie bat collectivement on va
tous faire l'effort pour se vacciner
pour encourager nos compatriotes de le
faire mais pour ça il faut donner une
sortie et quantifiables et vérifiables
et c'est justement de permettre ces
douze mille ce critère de 12000
hospitalisation sur une certaine durée 7
jours pour pas que ça change a tout à
tout les joueurs toutes les semaines qui
permettrait justement abandonné de
donner une issue à nos compatriotes
claire et précise merci quel est l'avis
de la commission sur chacun des trois
amendements
l'avis défavorable
madame la présidente le premier rejoint
sur des points essentiels de la position
de la commission l'amendement présenté à
l'instant par monsieur le ministre
et donc nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
le deuxième
soulève une difficulté majeure et il
parle du taux de déprogrammation mais il
n'existe pas de taux de déprogrammation
l'instrument statistique n'existe pas
donc vous ne pouvez pas fonder le pass
vaccinale sur une mesure qui n'est pas
fait du nombre de déprogrammation
d'ailleurs généralement on nie
l'existence même des déprogrammations ce
qui est d'ailleurs évidemment très
surprenant puisqu'il y à bien des
déprogrammations et qu'elle des
programmations il ya des
des degrés d'urgence différentes pour
les interventions chirurgicales qui
peuvent être programmés alors je suis
moi très sensibles et nous en avons
d'ailleurs déjà longuement débattu au
fait que l'hôpital aujourd'hui ne doit
pas voir la pression s'accentuer sur lui
avant d'avoir repris un mode de
fonctionnement normal c'est à dire
d'avoir
réalisé toutes les interventions
chirurgicales qui auront été déprogrammé
mais je ne sais pas le mesurer avec
l'instrument que vous proposez la seule
manière je crois d'en tenir compte c'est
de fixer un bon seuil en deçà duquel on
ne doit pas supprimer le pass vaccinale
parce que s'il y a
mettons encore 11 huile 12000 quinze
mille vingt mille personnes
hospitalisées pour le coc ville il se
trouve que la situation d'un hôpital qui
est largement exemple aujourd'hui
entraîne des déprogrammations mais si on
descend en dessous de dix mille avec une
capacité hospitalière de 400 mille lits
on peut se dire raisonnablement que les
l'opération des programmes et or ont pu
avoir lieu c'est pour moi de manière
approximative le meilleur moyen de
réaliser l'objectif que porte cet
amendement donc madame de sidrac avec
vos collègues je donne un avis
défavorable parce que si on prenait
votre amendement je crois
malheureusement qui ne serait pas
applicable et on aurait perdu
l'avantagent d'un amendement qui lui est
applicable même s'il est un peu
approximatif il faut bien le reconnaître
enfin je ne peux pas non plus donné un
avis favorable à l'amendement numéro
77 qui prend pour seul critère lui le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées pour
justifier le maintien ou non du pass
vaccinale faire très attention parce que
si on attend qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de personnes hospitalisées pour
mettre en application le pass vaccinale
on risque de ne pas prévenir justement
langage l'engorgement de l'hôpital en
l'appliquant un peu plus tôt c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons posée à
la commission des lois trois critères
nombre
d'hospitalisations au plan national
vitesse de circulation du virus au plan
local mais aussi
nombre de personnes vaccinées au plan
local quand beaucoup de gens sont
vaccinés et que le virus circule peu si
l'hôpital n'est pas sous une tension
excessive au plan national alors
automatiquement le pass vaccinale doit
être supprimée voilà la logique de la
position de la commission et nous nous
en tenons bien sûr à cette position avis
défavorable aux trois amendements
monsieur le ministre l avis du
gouvernement merci madame la présidente
j'ai le monsieur le sénateur
l'amendement du gouvernement ayant reçu
un avis défavorable n'y ont pas été
votée le gouvernement émettra un avis
favorable sur le 182 qui même s'il ne
restaure pas totalement la version de la
date de l'assemblée de l'assemblée
nationale tel que nous le souhaitions
par l'amendement numéro 200 il en
partage l'esprit et raison pour laquelle
nous émettons un avis favorable sur les
amendements numéro 6 et 77 al'inverse là
aussi pour suivant la logique qui est la
nôtre qui n'est de ne pas partager
l'esprit des critères qui ont été dé
cette logique de critères tels que
adopté en commission ces amendements qui
visent à faire varier ses critères nous
ne nous les refusons et ce sera donc un
avis défavorable sur le 6 rectifier le
77 rectifié mans
monsieur benarroch
la discussion qu'il y allait avoir lieu
est un peu ce réaliste je trouve en fait
on voit bien que parmi nous beaucoup y
compris notre rapporteur philippe val et
beaucoup de mes collègues sénateurs voit
bien la limite
pour pas dire plus de du vote d'un
nouveau pass vaccinale chacun d'entre
nous voit bien que oui peut-être mais à
quelles conditions et comment faire en
sorte en gros que le gouvernement ne
puisse pas décider lui-même de
l'arrêt ou de repasser devant le sénat
où l'assemblée nationale pour faire
arrêter ce pass vaccinale de personnes
est persuadé qu'il va avoir des effets
sur la propagation du virus ou sur la
situation sanitaire de la france et donc
chacun propose des critères pour faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une automaticité de
l'art et du pass vaccinale je comprends
bien la démarche j'approuve la démarche
mais les critères qui sont choisis on
l'a bien vu ils peuvent être disparate
ils peuvent être choisies par les uns
par les autres fonctions d'un certain
nombre d'éléments qui ne sont pas
partagées ils peuvent permettre une
territorialisation mai il a bien été
montré qu une territorialisation pouvait
être compliqué à appliquer pouvait
éventuellement même complique énormément
les choses d'un département lot d'une
ville à l'autre sur des critères qui ne
sont pas 6 donc tout ça pour dire qu'en
fait là nous venons de prouver par
l'absurde
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur et chers collègues qu fait le
vote du pacs vaccinale n'était
réellement pas approprié à notre
situation qu'il ne répondait à aucun
caractère d'urgence ni même deux
d'utilité dans la lutte pour nos
concitoyens contre
la propagation du virus et donc en fait
je ne voterai pas je n'étais pas
d'accord avec l'abonnement de la
commission je ne voterai au cas de ces
trois amendements et j'espère que cela
nous persuadera de ne pas voter la loi
au final pour ses positions
madame 2 idrac
qui à monsieur le rapporteur de toutes
les explications qu'il a données
s'agissant de l'amendement que j'ai
déposé je crois qu'il était nécessaire
j'avais besoin de vous entendre monsieur
le rapporteur sur le sujet de la
déprogrammation dans les hôpitaux qui me
semble un critère aussi indispensable à
prendre en considération dans cette
période de pandémie mais vous m'avez
convaincu et je suis tout à fait
rassurée sur les conditions que vous
même au niveau de la commission des lois
et des critères que vous avez introduit
sur le nombre de lits d'hospitalisation
vous avez parlé de trois critères je ne
vais pas les citer et donc je vais
retirer mon amendement c'est monsieur
savard et
merci
moi je pense que c'est un sujet
essentiel
parce que si on part du principe que la
vaccination est indispensable que ça
limite la gravité des conséquences et en
conséquence
ceux qui sont vaccinées ou quelque part
fin pas de protection collective et il
est tout à fait légitime que lorsque se
passe sanitaire qui transforme en passe
vaccinale qui contraint tout le monde il
est tout à fait légitime qu on l'arrête
ski libérez donne un peu plus de liberté
à des gens qui ont refusé la vaccination
mais que quand tous ceux qui ont accepté
la vaccination mais claire ont des
pathologies qui ont été déprogrammés
retardait avec une perte de chance ont
eu l'opportunité
de combler ce retard
parce que sinon il ya quelque chose qui
va pas
c'est un but de protection des gens non
vaccinés le pass vaccinale mais
également me semble-t-il d'incitation et
on
repense bien sûr aux propos du président
de la république qui souhaite vraiment
enquiquiner ceux qui ne jouent pas ce
nom pas ce jeu mais ce rôle civique de
se vacciner donc derrière il faut pas
que ceux qui ont joué leur rôle et qui
sont retardés parce qu'ils ont une
pathologie soit pénalisé donc faut
prendre en compte la résorption de la
déprogrammation ça me paraît essentiel
autour de de l'équité par rapport à la
maladie donc merci de faire un effort
dans ce sens là il ya cet amendement moi
j'ai proposé un être un amendement je
comprends pas pourquoi il est pas en
même temps il a un autre très bon face à
ray choses sont ainsi faites peu importe
mais je crois qu'il faut prendre en
compte on remercie faire des
propositions qui non seulement prennent
en compte le l'évolution de la maladie
ça c'est la partie qu'ovide mais c'est
toutes les conséquences connexes à cette
pathologie qu'il faut prendre en compte
parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison que
soient pénalisés ceux qui ont des
pathologies qui n'ont pas été prises en
compte richard
et me rappeler
un autre rapporteur l'état du droit
d'aujourd'hui sans son amendement les
mesures prescrites en application du
présent article sont strictement
proportionnées aux risques sanitaires et
appropriée aux circonstances de temps et
de lieu il y ait mis fin sans délai
lorsqu'elles ne sont plus nécessaires il
me semble qu'en bonne législation
ceux ci parfaitement suffisant remet la
liberté ou la responsabilité au
gouvernement ce contrôle du juge et avec
des rapports fréquents au parlement et
que par conséquent vous avez essayé de
monter un petit gazomètre qui risquent
d'être à certains moments un peu
explosif et qu'il y en avait nul besoin
janvier
merci madame la présidente
moi je trouvais que les deux amendements
celui de madame sidrac et celui de
monsieur chanterelle au fond ne
s'excusait pas et qu'ils avaient tous
les deux un mérite par rapport à la
rédaction actuelle c'est d'évacuer un
critère qui n'en est pas un en
l'occurrence que la circulation du virus
parce que si le virus le virus peut
circuler s'il n'a pas de conséquences
sur le système de santé sur les hôpitaux
qui n'entraîne pas des programmations
qui n'entraîne pas trente mille
hospitalisation ma foi c'est pas la
peine d'avoir des dispositifs
tel que le pass vaccinale enfin bon
voilà et donc le problème de la
rédaction du rapporteur c'est qu'il
introduit un critère de circulation
active du virus
d'ailleurs qu'il ne quantifie pas
mais qui ne fait pas sens alors que le
critère proposé par madame sidrac et
celui proposé par monsieur chanterelle
eux peuvent faire sens voilà et donc moi
j'aurais voté les deux amendements comme
adam ii sidrac retire le sien
soutiendrai celui de monsieur
chanterelles et tout ça ne nous fait pas
oublier
effectivement votre casque ali un autre
collègue benarroch que le pass vaccinale
de toute façon sur la circulation virale
est d'un intérêt extrêmement limitées
comme le pas de sanitaires mais si on va
porter
je voudrais dire à notre collègue alain
richard que je partage sa confiance à
l'égard du juge naturellement mais en
traque contrôle exercé par le juge ait
un contrôle exercé par le parlement qui
limite les pouvoirs de l'administration
et des gouvernements je choisis le
contrôle exercé par le parlement
très bien
c'est donc maintenant m voit d'abord
l'amendement 182 cas reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission est
favorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le 77 double avis défavorable qui
et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous avons maintenant deux
autres amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le saut veine de
monsieur benarroch
nous assistons on l'a dit on va aller
plusieurs fois depuis le début de
l'étude de la loi des records de
contamination depuis quelques jours sont
repartis du à la contagiosité du barrio
au micron sont aussi repartis du haut à
l'accroissement considérable du nombre
de tests effectués et vaccinés ce dock à
la fois contaminés et contaminant aussi
pour maintenir son cap de durcissement
du pass pour satisfaire un objectif plus
politique que sanitaire le gouvernement
entend pouvoir laisser le premier
ministre hôte de telles restrictions et
l'âge où ils demandent un peu
d'attention
parce que sur un mot le texte a changé
et c'est important
non dans l'intérêt de la santé publique
et au seul fait de lutter contre la
propagation de l'épidémie de kovy 19 ce
qui était jusqu'à présent le texte qui
figurait dans toutes les propositions
tous les projets de lois qui nous ont
été proposées mais dans l'intérêt de la
santé publique au seul fait de lutter
contre l'épidémie du coup vite 19 theron
lutte plus comme dans tous les textes
précédents contre la propagation
d'épidémies mais on lutte contre
l'épidémie ce changement peut vous
paraître finalement pas très important
pourtant la disparition du terme
propagation comme socle légal pour ces
décrets qui sont parfois contestée
devant les tribunaux
permet ainsi de fait au gouvernement de
prendre des mesures qui ne répondent
plus à aucun objectif sanitaire de lutte
contre la circulation du virus
je sais bien monsieur que le monsieur le
ministre a répondu que cette suppression
répondait d'une recommandation du
conseil d'état et pourtant si le terme
propagation doit disparaître selon vous
et là je cite encore le ministre c'est
que la diffusion du virus est trop
importante au stade auquel nous sommes
c'est bien en dessous si votre
gouvernement à abandonner volontairement
la bataille contre la propagation du
virus dont les conséquences seraient
atténués par un vaccin protecteur
évitant les formes graves aux tableaux
tous
plus en plus nombreux seront versés
madame muller bronn pour l'amendement 1
122 pardon 16
merci madame la présidente alors cet
amendement a pour objectif de préciser
que le taux d'incidence
soit celui de la maladie et non celui du
nombre de cas ou du portage du virus
aujourd'hui en effet le virus se propage
activement mais la détection du coc vide
à travers des tests par dizaines de
millions ne renseigne pas précisément
sur l'état de l'épidémie puisqu'il
s'agit de chiffrer le nombre de cas et
non pas le nombre de malades en effet
pour rendre compte de la situation
épidémique réel un test positif doit
être corrélés à des signes cliniques
c'est à cette condition que nous
connaissons véritablement le nombre
exact de malades c'est ce que fait le
réseau sentinelles qui dénombre chaque
semaine les personnes malades c'est à
dire avec des symptômes
introduire le suivi des cas
symptomatiques en s'appuyant sur les
réseaux classiques de suivi des
épidémies permettra de suivre de manière
plus pertinente la réalité de la
situation épidémique sur le territoire
tel est l'objet de cet amendement je
précise que cet amendement avait déjà
été adoptée dans le texte du sénat sur
le précédent projet de loi sur la
vigilance sanitaire
malheureusement il avait été rejeté à
l'assemblée pourtant compter les vrais
malades me semble être du bon sens et me
sur un porteur votre avis
l'avis est défavorable pour le 122 et
j'ai bien écouté madame miller brawn la
commission a été convaincu par son
amendement numéro 16 l'avait donc
favorable monsieur le ministre un avis
défavorable à deux amendements merci je
vais donc vous mettre aux voix d'abord
l'amendement sow 22 kg a reçu un double
avis défavorable qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstiennent n'est pas
adopté le 16 mars un avis favorable de
la commission est défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté nous avons
maintenant un amendement 76 qui le
présente monsieur soeur monsieur
questeur vous avez la parole
si madame la présidente
dans le contexte de la crise sanitaire
que nous connaissons qui s'accompagne
d'une crise économique et sociale
il faut noter qu'il y a de grandes
inégalités
y compris des inégalités sociales et
territoriales
face à cette pandémie
plusieurs rapports ont détruit en 2020 à
ce sujet il reste toujours pertinents
donc
cet amendement vise tout simplement à
dire que la politique
consistant à aller vers les gens
consistant à développer les centres de
vaccination de proximité
d'avorter toutes les aides nécessaires
de faire fonctionner les services
publics comme il le faut tout cela doit
être mise en oeuvre dans une perspective
sociale de réduction des inégalités
sociales et territoriales
c'est très clair il y a des quartiers ou
par rapport à la pandémie il y a
malheureusement moins de moyens que dans
d'autres quartiers ça a été cité dans le
débat c'est d'après midi il y à des
situations que ce soit dans le monde
rural ou dans le monde urbain où il y à
de grandes difficultés
des difficultés plus forte qu'ailleurs
donc je ne comprendrais pas mes chers
collègues il faudrait m'expliquer
pourquoi il y aurait un inconvénient
a mentionné que la politique vaccinale
eux
se déroule de manière à réduire les
inégalités
territoriales et sociales
quel est l'avis de la commission en aide
à mon enfance et
croyez bien chers collègues que la
commission partage votre objectif de
réduire les inégalités territoriales et
sociales dans l'accès à la vaccination
mais ne me semble pas quand puisse
mettre cet objectif au même niveau que
les objectifs de rétablissement de la
sécurité sanitaire face à la propagation
de l'épidémie qui sont ce ces pouvoirs
exceptionnels donc l'avis est
défavorable
ministre merci madame la présidente
monsieur le questeur monsieur le
sénateur sur nous nous partageons au
gouvernement également cet objectif de
réduction des inégalités territoriales
et sociales dans l'accès à la
vaccination mais christian lepage
nationale ne nous semble pas être le
l'outil pertinent pour pour y aboutir et
pour autant vous vous dire repartager re
réaffirmé le fait que le gouvernement a
mis en place depuis plusieurs mois
différentes actions d'aller vers cette
allée vers que vous appeliez de votre
pour favoriser la vaccination des
personnes les plus isolées les plus les
plus précaires les plus éloignés du
système de santé j'en cite quelques unes
l'envoi de courriers de sms dans ce
numéro coup fil pour prendre rendez-vous
la mobilisation d'unités mobiles de
vaccination la sensibilisation des
médecins traitants pour faire de la
vaccination à domicile la mise en oeuvre
d'opérations de vaccination dans les
centres d'hébergement d'urgence dans les
hôtels sociaux dans certaines
universités
l'organisation de permanence dans des
relais alimentaire associatif pour aider
à la prise de rendez-vous à la prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie des frais
de transport vers un cabinet médical ou
un centre de vaccination pour les
personnes qui rencontrent des
difficultés à se déplacer voilà monsieur
le sénateur au total à la date du
dernier bilan qui a été menée ça remonte
déjà au 7 octobre dernier dont il ya
plus de trois mois on dénombrait déjà
plus de 4000 opération de ce type
ciblées sur les personnes précaires sur
les personnes éloignées de notre système
de soins de vaccination et ce système
ces dispositifs d'aller vers ont permis
la vaccination d'un 1,2 million de
patients qui ont été vaccinés grâce à
ces dispositifs la voilà donc une fois
encore le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour atteindre ces personnes il
n'y a pas que des dents les personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés évidemment que
des antilles vaxillaire aussi des
personnes qui sont isolées et nous
mobilisons les moyens depuis le début de
la crise pour
aller à leur rencontre et leur permettre
d'accéder aux soins et à la vaccination
est défavorable madame après c'est
la présidente j'ai mis mes chers
collègues donc notre collègue monsieur
sur indique effectivement qu'il faut
aller vers un objectif de privilégier
effectivement la politique publique de
vaccination je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lui mais je voudrais lui dire
combien dans nos départements notamment
nos départements ruraux il ya un travail
considérable des infirmières des
médecins des collectivités des sapeurs
pompiers
et on peut dire que vraiment il ya une
mobilisation de tous pour que les
personnes isolées soient vaccinés
monsieur je me
oui merci madame la présidente
l'amendement de jean pierre sueur quand
même il pose une question qui est
essentielle parce que monsieur mini son
nom on entend bien la liste que vous
faites des opérations d'aller vers mais
la réalité c'est que les inégalités
territoriales ne se sont pas réduites
les inégalités sociales dans la
vaccination quand vous regardez les
écarts les écarts restent identiques en
gros quand vous êtes dans une catégorie
socio professionnelles favorisées vous
êtes très vacciner et quand vous êtes
dans les catégories sociales les plus
basses vous êtes beaucoup moins vacciner
quand vous êtes dans un territoire qui
est en difficulté
vous êtes beaucoup moins vacciner que
quand vous êtes dans un arrondissement
parisien favoriser et donc le comblement
de ces inégalités sociales et
territoriales ne disons pas que le
gouvernement n'a pas mis en place des
actions nous disons qu'elles sont
insuffisantes et qu'elles n'ont pas
apporté de réduction de ces inégalités
sociales et territoriales
or ça devrait être et c'est ce que dit
l'amendement de jean pierre sueur un
objectif principal comme le sont les
objectifs de sécurité sanitaire 1 le
rapporteur a rappelé pour l'ensemble de
la population
ces deux objectifs doivent être
complémentaires et c'est exactement ce
que dit cet amendement il demande au
fonds au gouvernement de travailler de
façon plus active à cette réduction est
de fait le nombre de primo vacciner est
resté totalement stable et très bas
depuis le début du mois d'octobre autour
de 20 à 25 milles par jour et pas plus
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 76 qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté de 188 monsieur rainville
merci madame le président de mes chers
collègues cet amendement de repli vise
comme tout repli à éviter la débâcle par
souci d'égalité ce dispositif proposé
d'appliquer aux étrangers souhaitant
résider dans notre pays pour une durée
d'au moins trois mois les mêmes
restrictions que celles qui pèse sur les
français il ne faudrait pas que les
français sont les plus mal lotis chez
eux c'est une précision de bon sens qui
entraîne une conséquence évidente en cas
de non respect de cette obligation les
étrangers feront l'objet d'une décision
administrative d'obligation de quitter
le territoire français tels que définis
à l'article un récit 111-1 du code de
l'entrée et du séjour des étrangers et
du droit d'asile mes chers collègues et
si vous rejetez cet amendement les
étrangers non vaccinés auront des droits
supérieurs aux français non vaccinés si
vous rejetez cet amendement on se calme
sur les fauteuils de la gauche si vous
rejetez cet amendement vous ferez des
français non vaccinés des résidents car
ils ne sont déjà plus des citoyens non
plus de seconde zone mais de troisième
zone dans leur propre pays j'en appelle
donc à la cohérence et à l'égalité de
touche tous égaux devant la loi y
compris devant la loi de l'emmerdement
maximum
quel est l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement libérable l'avis du
gouvernement
panneaux
double avis défavorable pied pour
qui est pour personne qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
dont acte
l'amendement 88 monsieur soeur et non
sur le président caennais madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la commission des lois à
juste titre a proposé d' encadrer
l'application du pass vaccinale dans le
temps conditionnant son application
selon plusieurs critères dont celui
prenant en compte 80 % de la population
ayant un schéma vaccinal complet
constatée au niveau départemental je
rapporteur nous voudrions aller plus
loin en tout cas être plus fraîchit en
proposant que pour l'appréciation de ce
critère il faudrait être sûr 80% de la
population éligible au vaccin cette
précision est nécessaire que la
vaccination contre la copie de 19 a été
proposée en priorité aux groupes
vulnérables puis a été étendue à
plusieurs catégories de la population
pour toute personne souhaitant se faire
vacciner il faut s'assurer qu'elle soit
éligible c'est à dire qu'elles fassent
partie des groupes prioritaires qu'elle
ne présente pas de critère d'exclusion
et on revient aux débats précédents de
l'amendement avec le temps les groupes
prioritaires on est évolué en fonction
de l'avancée de la campagne de
vaccination en outre les critères
d'exclusion sont également susceptibles
d'évoluer en fonction des types de
vaccins disponibles et de l'avancée des
connaissances médicales qui sont devant
nous viser 80 % de la population
générale n'aurait donc pas de sens selon
nous c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons cet ajout du qualificatif
éligibilité qui nous semblent
pertinentes
l'avis de la commission
merci madame la présidente j'ai examiné
avec soin cet amendement parce que je le
crois constructif dans son inspiration
il modifie les paramètres de la prise en
compte du nombre de vaccinés pour la
décision d'appliquer ou de ne pas
appliquer le pass
vaccinale je rappelle d'ailleurs que ça
n'est qu'une des trois conditions les
deux autres étant le nombre
d'hospitalisations au plan national et
la vitesse de circulation
de l'épidémie du virus au plan local
ma difficulté
avec votre amendement ce sont ses effets
imaginons que les deux autres conditions
soient réunies pour
lever le pass vaccinale en prenant en
compte 80 % de la population de plus de
cinq ans et non pas 80% de la population
de plus de 12 ans on aboutit quand même
à un effet de bord comme on dit
couramment aujourd'hui assez important
puisque actuellement tous les
départements sauf 8
ont moins de 80 % de la population de
plus de 12 ans vaccinée donc la barre
dans le texte de la commission est quand
même assez haute pour supprimer le pass
vaccinale tandis qu'avec votre
amendement la suppression du pass
vaccinale interviendrait beaucoup plus
vite puisque nous avons à peu près le
tiers impute un petit peu moins du tiers
sans doute de département qui déjà sont
à plus de 80%
de la population de plus de 5 ans c'est
la raison pour laquelle la commission
après avoir examiné tous ces éléments de
fond à penser que on baisserait lagarde
trop vite si on adopter votre amendement
alors ce qui me satisfait dans votre
proposition néanmoins c'est que vous
rentrez dans la logique de des critères
qui sont posées qui nous permettent de
ne pas attendre le 31 juillet si la cie
la situation sanitaire s'améliore pour
que le gouvernement soit obligé
que ce soit pas pour lui une décision
discrétionnaire sous le contrôle du juge
qu'ils soient obligées de lever au moins
progressivement le pass vaccinale c'est
pourquoi je vous remercie de cet effort
que vous avez porté au nom de votre
groupe monsieur le président mais
malheureusement je ne peux pas donner un
avis favorable compte tenu de ces
éléments de fond que j'ai mentionné
monsieur le ministre oui une fois encore
pour l'aider pour les arguments que j'ai
eu l'occasion de développer nous sommes
pas favorables à l'inscription dans la
loi de critères chiffrés c'est la raison
pour laquelle se mettront un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement même si
prise en compte la population vous
évoquez sur le fond semblait plus
cohérente si on s'y tenté qu'on devait
rentrer dans ce système là mais que
auquel nous n'adhérons auquel nous
n'adhérons pas vous l'avez compris donc
des femmes madame de la gontrie
merci mr le président j'écoute toujours
avec beaucoup d'intérêt
les interventions du rapporteur et du
coup j'essaie de comprendre parce que
lorsque nous avons débattu dans cet
hémicycle il y a quelques mois seulement
j'ai le souvenir d'une discussion qui
avait d'ailleurs vous en rappelez
peut-être susciter une suspension de
séance un petit peu longue trop longue
au goût de collègues et avait été voté
par le sénat
ce pourcentage
80% et de population éligible donc je ne
comprends pas très bien pourquoi à
l'heure où nous parlons finalement ce
critère ne conviendrait pas alors même
que le volume de population éligible est
plus important puisque désormais les
enfants de plus de cinq ans peuvent être
vaccinés donc est ce que je comprends
simplement que voilà vous avez décidé de
changer d'avis parce que vous êtes
toujours très pertinents donc si vous
étiez pertinent en octobre comment
êtes-vous pertinent également en janvier
je dois dire que j'ai un petit peu de
difficulté monsieur le rapporteur donc
voter notre amendement
je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement 88 qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
allons maintenant aborder 45 amendement
faisant l'objet d'une décision commune
mais je vais déjà vous aider en vous
suggérant d'abandonner la liasse
d'amendements lilas qui vous avaient été
distribués au profit de l'allier un
amendement abricots qui vous a été donné
à la place
et nous allons donc maintenant que
chacun la bonne liasse de la bonne
couleur devant lui commencez par
l'amendement 178
monsieur klinger c'est vous qui le
défendent et
merci madame la présidente
l'article 1er du présent projet de loi
vise à transformer le pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale ce dernier en est en
étant plus restrictive que le premier
par ailleurs il est regrettable de voir
que le dépistage virologiques et le
certificat de rétablissement soit des
armes a désormais totalement exclue au
profit du statut vaccinal uniquement
cette mesure n'aura que pour seul effet
que de resserrer l'étau liberticide que
le gouvernement monte en puissance un
peu plus à chaque texte d'urgence sur la
crise sanitaire en conséquence il est
nécessaire d'en circonscrire au maximum
l'utilisation et d'en définir les
modalités
d'application en passant du pass
sanitaire au pass vaccinale le
gouvernement fait le choix de se passer
des tests alors que c'est un outil plus
fiable pour garantir la non contagiosité
le présent amendement propose donc de
laisser aux français les plus jeunes et
donc les moins à risque la liberté
d'apporter la preuve qu'ils ne sont pas
malades par un autre moyen que le statut
vaccinal le présent amendement propose
donc de fonder l'application du pass
vaccinale aux seules personnes de plus
de 50 ans l'âge de 50 ans retenu
correspond à l'âge auquel on observe une
nette augmentation du taux
d'hospitalisation en soins critiques ces
dernières semaines 50 ans c'est aussi
par exemple l'âge qu'a choisi le
gouvernement italien pour rendre la
vaccination obligatoire cet âge de 50
ans mais ça me semble donc être le bon
seuil d'entrée pour le pass vaccinale le
pass sanitaire étant largement
satisfaisant pour les plus jeunes
le 184 monsieur richard
dans le texte qui vient de l'assemblée
on a conservé l'âge limite de 16 ans
pour appliquer
l'obligation du paf vaccinale qui
devient
le passé un solitaire qui devient le
pass vaccinale pourquoi parce que nous
nous sommes entendus depuis maintenant
le début de cette crise pour considérer
que 16 ans et est l'âge auquel les
jeunes étaient en mesure de choisir
eux-mêmes de se faire vacciner il n'y a
plus besoin d'accords des parents il
nous semble donc que c'est l'âge qu'on
doit garder comme pivot pour donner une
dispense pour permettre l'accès sur
simple parce ça l'hiver donc avec art
avec un test négatif pour les activités
de loisirs telles qu'elles sont définies
dans la loi depuis le début nous semble
donc que le basculement à 18 ans qui a
été proposé par le rapporteur est adopté
par la commission est inadaptée qu'il
vaut mieux rester à le début de saison
monsieur ravier pour les 189
merci merci madame la présidente que
puisque vous avez décidé d'acter le pass
vaccinale
cet amendement de repli propose d'en
réduire le périmètre en laissant toute
personne de moins de 40 ans libre de se
vacciner ou non sans lui imposer de
contraintes vaccinale au lieu de 18 ans
dans la version actuelle du texte à ce
jour 79 % des 12 17 ans 92 % des 18-29
ans et 88% des 30-39 ans bénéficie d'un
schéma vaccinal complet c'est le fruit
de la liberté vaccinale pour certains
mais aussi de la contrainte suscité par
l'onss vaille sanitaire aujourd'hui en
vigueur par une pour une grande part
d'entre vous avez fait le choix de la
contrainte pourtant l'inefficacité du
vaccin sur la propagation du virus a été
prouvée par l'observation scientifique
de nouveau record de personnes
contaminées en france sont établies
alors que la grande majorité des
français est vacciné et si
grande difficulté frappe aujourd'hui les
urgences c'est que comme en 2012 déjà
lors de l'épidémie seulement de grippe
l'hôpital a été sacrifié sur l'autel de
la rigueur budgétaire dans ce texte nous
sommes passés arbitraire au monde un
seuil d'âge de 12 à 16 ans puis de 16 à
18 au vu des données de santé publique
france pourquoi pas quarante
selon ces données officielles depuis le
mois d'avril 2020 des personnes
appartenant à la tranche d'âge 20 39 en
europe entre 0,4 pour cent des décès
hospitaliers et 4 % de personnes en
réanimation tandis que les héros 19 ans
représentent 0 02 % des décès
hospitaliers et 0,6 des personnes en
réanimation des moins de 40 ans ne sont
pas le public cible des dangers de cette
maladie de plus le 8 novembre 2021 la
haute autorité de santé a déconseillé
aux personnes de moins de 30 ans de se
faire administrer le vaccin du
laboratoire moderna on observe à quel
point les certitudes du jour ne sont pas
celle du lendemain la balance bénéfice
risque favorable à une exclusion du pass
sanitaire des publics les plus jeunes et
raisonnablement jusqu'à 40 ans par cet
amendement il convient donc de réduire
les effets économiques politiques et
sanitaires nuisibles du pass vaccinale
je vous prie de libérer la jeunesse de
france en faisant un accueil favorable à
cet amendement madame noël le 56 ans
actif yelly oui merci madame la
présidente j'en profitais pour présenter
mes deux amendements donc qui ont pour
objet d'exclure lusage du pass sanitaire
enfin vaccinale des lieux de culture et
des activités sportives
s'agissant des lieux de culture et bien
je pense qu'il s'agit de lieux où le
respect des gestes barrières et
probablement autant possible que dans
une grande surface donc je pense que l'
usage du pass sanitaires et vaccinal
semble superflu et s'agissant des
activités sportives il s'agit là d'une
mesure de bon sens puisque la pratique
sportive a été considérablement affecté
durant cette crise sanitaire les
français s'en sont beaucoup pellois nier
ce qui pose beaucoup de soucis de santé
publique de sédentarité on sait que la
sédentarité et l'obésité sont des
facteurs aggravants du coc vite donc je
vous propose d'exclure le pass vaccinale
de ses activités tomassi merci monsieur
monsieur
arnaud je crois
voilà messieurs arnaud pour le 112
oui mais le président tous ses ministres
ou chers collègues lorsqu'on regarde les
informations présentes sur les
certificats de vaccination tels qu'ils
s'affichent dans l'application anti
qu'ovide deux éléments apparaissent non
la personne la date de naissance sont
donc ces informations que des
professionnels que ce soit les
bistrotiers les restaurateurs seraient
amenés à vérifier en les comparant avec
ceux d'un document officiel identité je
vous rappelle que les trois seules
reconnues par l'administration sur la
carte d'identité le passeport est permis
de conduire or le contrôle d'identité
est une prérogative des forces de
l'ordre
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
vous le savez a souhaité distinguer la
notion de contrôler l'identité de celle
de concordance d'identité j'entends la
nuance je vous propose néanmoins de
résoudre à la fois ce débat sur sanne
sur cette nuance et surtout de réaliser
de réduire par dont le risque d'exposer
les professionnels à des tensions avec
leurs clients et d'atténuer leur charge
de travail en intégrant dans le
dispositif du pass sanitaire une
photographie de son titulaire
par conséquent cette disposition
permettrait une simplification de
procédure tant pour les citoyens que
pour les responsables d'établissements
soumis à l'obligation de présentation du
pass vaccinale il ne modifie en rien le
droit en vigueur permettant toujours aux
forces de l'ordre de contrôler
l'identité de la personne en complément
du pass vaccinale de se croit cette
solution - attentatoires des eaux
libertés individuelles et plus
opérationnels permettrait effectivement
doté dans le texte qui nous est proposé
les alinéas prévoyant le contrôle
d'identité par les personnes chargées de
vérifier le pass vaccinale ce rien donc
ainsi supprimés je pense que cette
disposition permettrait d'alléger les
contraintes sur les professionnels et
faire en sorte effectivement que les
choses soient plus faciles tout en étant
effectivement plus contrôler et de
limiter autant que possible notamment
les fraudes au pass vaccinale je vous
remercie mes cheveux mi longs pour le 60
merci la présidente
l'amendement est identique à celui qui
vient d'être présentée mais l'objet
n'est pas le même en effet l'utilisation
frauduleuse du pass vaccinale peut avoir
on le sait on l'a vu d'ailleurs les
conséquences particulièrement graves y
compris mortel pour les personnes qui
ont recours il convient donc de les
protéger en permettant de connaître
réellement leur état de santé en cas de
contamination par l'e.coli 19 afin de
pouvoir les traiter efficacement
imposer la photographie du titulaire sur
justificatif du statut vaccinal
concernant la copie 19 permet de limiter
les risques d'usurpation d'identité est
d'usagé frauduleux ce document
garantissant ainsi une meilleure prise
en charge du cas échéant en outre ce
document alliant photographie nom et
prénom de la personne renforce la
transparence et permet de protéger
l'ensemble des personnes présentant ses
dieux en garantissant retenter la
situation vaccinale et sanitaires de
chaque participant si madame noël
merci madame la présidente cet
amendement vise à interdire le pass
vaccinale et sanitaires pour les mineurs
pour des questions de santé et des tic
conformément aux préconisations du
comité national d'éthique dont le
président jean françois delfraissy
déclaré je cite le pass sanitaire de
noah ne doit pas concerner les ados las
les adolescents et les enfants le recul
existe on ne permet pas d'assurer la
pleine sécurité de ces nouveaux vaccins
chez l'adolescent les conséquences de la
pandémie sur la santé psychologique et
mentale des enfants et surtout des
adolescents sont profondes et
probablement durable s'agissant de
l'immunité collective est il éthique de
faire supporter aux mineurs la
responsabilité en termes de bénéfice
collectif du refus de la vaccination
d'une partie de la population adulte le
bénéfice des vaccins sur les enfants et
les adolescents n'est pas avéré les
adolescents développe en effet moins de
forme grave en france les moins de 18
ans représentent 1,1 pour cent du total
des hospitalisations
0.9 pourtant dû du total d admission en
soins critiques le recours au vaccin
pour la tranche 12 18 ans était
initialement préconisé pour empêcher la
transmission du virus et il n'est
apparemment plus justifiée puisque le
vaccin n'empêche pas la transmission le
rapport bénéfices risques de la
vaccination chez les plus jeunes n'étant
pas démontrée il convient de faire
preuve de la plus grande vigilance à
l'égard de notre jeunesse et de ne pas
inciter inutilement les plus jeunes à se
faire vacciner
j'ajouterai par ailleurs que les
quelques justifications qui ont été
apportées par la commission pour
supprimer le pass vaccinale en faveur
des moins de 16 ans là aussi n'est pas
satisfaisant puisque quel parent pourra
recourir aussi régulièrement que toutes
les 24 heures impasse sanitaires pour
permettre à ces enfants d'avoir l'usagé
ses activités donc là encore une fois ce
n'est pas suffisant voilà sur nation
monsieur lévy le 37 rectifier
oui madame la présidente
j'ai mis mes chers collègues cet
amendement concerne la population qui
veut se faire vacciner mais qui ne peut
pas le faire pour des raisons médicales
si on retire à des personnes le droit de
pouvoir se déplacer d'exercer les
activités alors même qu'elles ne peuvent
pas se faire vacciner la loi crée une
situation inéquitable parmi la
population française
législature doit donc prévoir des outils
de substitution pour les personnes qui
ne peuvent pas se faire vacciner en
raison de troubles de pathologies qui
serait incompatible avec la vaccination
contre la copie de 19 alors je pense
particulièrement à des personnes
allergiques savez certaines personnes
qui ont fait un choc anaphylactique
lire la première injection du vaccin qui
qui sont allergiques un produit qui est
le polyéthylène glycol qui est contenu
dans les vaccins et le message des types
modern haifa isr et donc vous avez ces
personnes qui se tournent vers leur
médecin traitant des siens traitants se
sent pas suffisamment compétent pour
justifier d'une incapacité de se faire
maquiller donc en bois vert un
allergologue et vous avez des
territoires notamment des territoires en
occitanie ou pour un rendez-vous en
occident avec un allergologue il faut à
peu près sept mois ce qui veut dire que
ces personnes aiment écouter attendent
patiemment et rendez vous pour faire un
test d'allergie et voir si elles peuvent
se faire ou non vacciner
pour éviter cette situation une
attestation personnel des librairies par
la grèce dont ils dépendent sur
prescription du médecin traitant
doré leur accorde une dérogation à leur
permette de continuer d'exercer leur
activité d'entrer dans les lieux
recevant du public grâce aux tests
virologiques et moins de 72 ans ne
concluront pas une contamination par
lacombe 19 tel est l'objet de cet
amendement
benaroch sipa
la présidente avant de défendre un
amendement juste une petite remarque de
candide qui est sûrement lié au fait que
je suis un jeune sénateur 5 pas
comprendre qu'on puisse étudier des
règles de 40 amendements que rien à voir
les uns avec les autres pour la clarté
de notre débat pour le fait que nous
devons obtenir des réponses du ministre
et des réponses de notre à porter pour
le fait que chacun d'entre nous doit se
positionner sur chaque amendement je ne
comprends pas qu'on ait pu imaginer
d'étudier 40 amendements à la queue leu
leu sans aucun rapport les uns avec les
autres c'est ce qu'a fait par exemple
tout à l'heure que mon amendement sur
les gestes barrières soient tombés parce
que l'amendement sur les jambes des
stades avait été votée je ne vois aucune
cohérence et aucune logique à cette
façon de travailler
une fois dit cela
alors qu'elle est l'amendement que je
propose l'amendement que je propose en
fait est liée au fait que le
gouvernement a souhaité inclure dans le
pass vaccinale accès aux transports
publics interrégionaux il l'a fait en se
basant sur un rapport du conseil d'état
qui rappelait aux gros que pour les
déplacements de longue distance ils
avaient admis leur inclusion dans le
pass eu égard aux effets attendus de la
mesure pour limiter la propagation de
l'épidémie essentiellement et l'estimé
que le contexte sanitaire aux
particuliers rediffusion du au micro
pouvait justifier ce renforcement des
mesures de protection dans les transport
longue distance pour il pour envisager
de diminuer la propagation du virus or
le ministre l'a encore rappelé il nous
l'a dit dans son nous disions dans son
audition au sénat le gouvernement le dis
à chaque fois ils ont supprimé ce texte
ne part pas dans l'objectif de lutter
contre la propagation de l'épidémie
terme qui n'est plus dans la loi et il a
même été supprimés des objectifs du
gouvernement puisque la diffusion du
virus est trop important dans la
situation actuelle
donc l'objectif du gouvernement n'existe
qu'en plus la justification du conseil
d'état pour extraire des transports
était régionaux dans le cadre de ce pass
vaccinale n'existe plus et ample de ce
fait donc de la même façon que la
justification top je demande que
l'amendement oh la la la position du
gouvernement top et donc je vous demande
de voter cet amendement afin que le pass
vaccinale ne soit pas demandée pour les
transports étaient régionaux madame noël
c'est encore vous pour le 43 rectifié
terre
il est défendue
non
pas 60 18 monsieur soeur
monsieur très rouge 78 merci madame la
présidente
dans la prolongation d'une certaine
façon de ce qu'a proposé notre collègue
mme benarroch nous proposons avec cet
amendement de ne pas appliquer le passé
accident le transport public
interrégionaux pour maintenir justement
la solution du pass sanitaire qui est
déjà en vigueur le projet de loi comme
vous savez impose le pass vaccinale dans
les déplacements de longue distance par
transports publics interrégionaux avec
une dérogation qui est prévu uniquement
4 justification d'un motif impérieux
d'ordre familial de santé et puis depuis
les travaux de notre commission des lois
professionnelles dans ce cas la
présentation d'un résultat le d'examens
de dépistage virologique ne concluront
pas à une contamination par l'e.coli de
19,2 sera demandée en cas d'urgence
faisant obstacle à l'obtention du
justificatif rocky ces dispositions ne
s'appliqueront pas la présente
disposition nous semble-t-il soulèvent
de sérieuses difficultés
que faut-il entendre par motifs
impérieux quels seront les justificatifs
susceptibles d'être admis par les
responsables chargés des contrôles et
les documents comment les contrôleurs et
les contrôleuses vont-ils apprécier ses
motifs l'imposition du pass vaccinale
pour l'accès aux services de transports
visées par le projet de loi porte nous
semble-t-il directement atteinte à la
liberté d'aller et venir et
potentiellement par ricochet à d'autres
doit-elle que le droit au respect de la
vie privée et familiale
or de telles restrictions doivent
s'avérer nécessaire mais également
proportionnée notamment en prévoyant des
mesures qui concilie au mieux les
objectifs recherchés la protection de la
santé publique et l'exercice des droits
et libertés certes le brassage de
populations canteraine à parcourent de
longues distances constitue un facteur
de risque de diffusion du virus pour
autant ce n'est pas un fait nouveau et
aggrave en justifiant l'adoption d'une
mesure plus restrictives par ailleurs
contrairement à ce qu'a expliqué le
ministre de la santé à l'assemblée
nationale les personnes ne disposant pas
d'un pass d'accident ne pourront pas
forcément utiliser un autre moyen de
transport il nous semble donc que pour
que l'ensemble des citoyens y compris
ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés mais qui
présente un test négatif puissent
circuler il faut adopter cet amendement
monsieur rainville 190
merci mme la présidente mais chers
collègues cet amendement vise à
supprimer le poste sanitaire et le pass
vaccinale pour les déplacements de
longue distance par transports publics
interrégionaux donc en train car il
représente pour beaucoup des
déplacements essentiel dans ce cas
précis la restriction de liberté est
manifestement disproportionnée par
rapport au but de préservation de la
protection de la santé permettez moi de
parler de mon propre cas de citoyens de
parlementaire et je vous invite à en
mesurer
l'inconstitutionnalité de cette mesure
en dehors du fait que je suis membre du
rassemblement national que je bois du
café deux bouts au bistrot que je mange
et boit dans le train comme mon
métabolisme melun pause je ne suis pas
vacciné je sais je cumule beaucoup de
tares et de friteries sûr mais c'est
ainsi je devrais donc dès la semaine
prochaine prendre ma voiture pour faire
huit heures de trajet aller et 8 heures
de trajet retour pour examiner loi votée
et contrôler l'action du gouvernement
avouer mes chers collègues que le bilan
carbone parce qu'en plus je roule au
diesel je roule au diesel je sais je
sais je suis un véritable criminel
je leur bilan carbone humains et
pécunier de cette opération est
scandaleusement disproportionnée
je suis donc matériellement dans
l'incapacité de remplir mon rôle de
législateur ou alors est ce à dire que
vous êtes en train de de voter une
obligation vaccinale déguisé en assumer
par le droit de monter dans le train
parce qu'on n'est pas vacciné par le
droit de prendre la voiture se serait
rendu coupable d'un écocide par le droit
de monter au sénat à cheval ce serait
une atteinte aux droits de l'animal ce
monde que vous nous offrez devient fou
vous offrez une vous ouvrez une boîte de
pandore on va tous finir à pied mais
jamais en marche lente travaux
parlementaires
exercé à mon encontre par ce texte ne
saurait cacher la situation de très
nombreux français travailleurs et
vaccine travailleurs et familles non
vaccinés c'est à dire n'ayant reçu
aucune une ou deux doses je le rappelle
deux doses dont le président de files
heures viennent de reconnaître
l'inéfficacité
puisque j'arrive à la fin je rage si
vous me le permettez maintenant la
présidente je rajouterais que la sncf a
déjà bien déjà bien mal en point a
annoncé une suppression de 10 % des tgv
et 20 % des intercités à partir de cette
semaine parce que vous allez choisir de
l'enfer peur qui va payer l'addition de
cette inconséquence surtout des pertes
provient donc des hommes sur
des adultes en votant cet amendement
merci madame la puce c'est à vous pour
le 126
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement va à la rencontre des
amendements 120 et 78 qui ont été
défendue récemment je rappellerai que la
loi du 31 mai 2021 relative à la gestion
de la crise prévoyait de dispenser d'un
passager terre de se dispenser d'un
passager d'air lorsque les déplacements
interrégionaux étaient des déplacements
pour des motifs impérieux familiaux ou
de santé ni justificatif de vaccination
ni testées négatives n'était alors
demandé nous souhaitons donc que cette
mesure soit conservée en cas d'urgence
il n'est pas toujours possible en raison
notamment des délais d'attentes de
disposer d'un test voilà le sens de cet
amendement le 127 meyrals fuhrmann oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre à travers cette âme cet
amendement pardo nous souhaitons faire
finalement que l'accès et la pratique du
droit pour tout justiciable ne soit pas
un droit soumis au contexte sanitaire
d'un droit qui s'applique coûte que
coûte puisqu'il est d'ailleurs
constitutifs de l'état de droit et il
constitue un des fondements de notre
pacte républicain
d'ailleurs malmenées ces derniers ces
derniers temps à travers cet amendement
est donc tel que précisé nous souhaitons
effectivement
exclure la justifie qu'un le
justificatif pardon de vaccination de
présentation de test négatif pour
pouvoir permettre l'exercice de l'accès
à la justice pour toutes et pour tous
merci madame tous les robert
merci madame la présidente
le présent amendement vise à maintenir
la possibilité de présenter un test
négatif pour les personnes en situation
d'apprentissage lorsqu'elles doivent se
déplacer par transport interrégionaux
dans le cas de leur formation il
complète ainsi l'exclusion des personnes
dont l'activité professionnelle ou la
recherche d'emploi imposé déplacements
de longue distance du champ de
l'application du pass vaccinale exiger
comme unique justificatifs l'absence de
dérogation à cette très strict on
pourrait aboutir à une discrimination
des apprentis fondée sur leur lieu de
résidence en effet un employeur pourrait
souhaiter éviter de signer une
convention avec un apprenti d'une autre
région susceptible de se voir refuser
l'accès au train en conséquent cet
amendement vise en quelque sorte à
compléter le projet de loi dans ce sens
je vous remercie madame noël le 46
merci madame la présidente cet
amendement a pour objet de faire face à
l'urgence impérieuse
durant laquelle il apparaît délicat de
demander l'obtention d'un résultat des
examens virologiques alors même que la
priorité du demandeur n'est pas à
l'opération d'un tel test il est donc
proposé de permettre à la personne de
fournir un test d'une validité de 72
heures mesure plus raisonnable pour les
personnes concernées cette disposition
d'autant plus nécessaire que les
laboratoires et les centres de dépistage
sont extrêmement engagée en ce moment
sont minces ils 257
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président monsieur minnis la loi du 31
mai 2021 sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire introduit à son article
premier l'obligation présenté a pas de
sanitaires pour se présenter dans un
établissement de santé social et
médico-social pour des soi pour ramer
cette obligation concerne les mains dans
les malades comme le raccompagne aux
accompagnants alors que l'absence de
lits et de personnels formés
supplémentaires depuis deux ans les
hôpitaux sont contraints de déprogrammer
les interventions et retable est prise
en charge des patients l'obligation de
présenter d'appât sanitaire invs le
renoncement aux soins et les
conséquences de pathologies telles sont
les raisons de la demande de suppression
de cette disposition merci
l'ebit semaine à madame noël merci
madame la présidente les mesures
restreignant l'accès aux services aux
établissements de santé contreviennent
aux principes fondamentaux de la
constitution
l'accès aux soins doit être libre et
garanties pour l'ensemble des citoyens
du territoire
l'application du pass inter pour accéder
aux soins est un non sens d'un point de
vue sanitaire il restera la possibilité
pour les citoyens de se faire soigner
dans des dérives qui ont été constatés
en l'espace de quelques mois le vaccin
ne permet pas de garantir une non
contagiosité des passions ou visiteurs à
l'hôpital la mesure ne paraît donc pas
justifié et je rappelle encore une fois
que l'application du pass sanitaire
coûte chaque mois à l'hôpital 60
millions d'euros le rapporteur pour le
coordination merci
il ne présente madame ma pour pouponner
merci madame la présidente donc cet
amendement de repli vise à exclure les
consultations santé mon mental soins
psychiatriques psychologiques et
psychothérapeutique de l'obligation de
présentation d'un pass vaccinale
d'impasse sanitaire alors que la
pandémie a fortement détérioré la santé
mentale de nos concitoyens et de nos
concitoyennes il semble indispensable de
maintenir l'accès aux professionnels de
santé mentale pour lesquels les
consultations téléphoniques ne sont pas
suffisantes et nécessitent des
consultations physique je pense aux
adolescents pour lesquels depuis
l'automne 2020 les professionnels
constatent une augmentation massive dans
les services d'urgences avec des
problématiques suicidaire
de passage à l'acte autoagressif qu'il
s'agisse de tentatives de suicide de
scarification d'auto mutilés ou
mutilation de conduites à risques qui
sont toutes des signes de détresse et de
désespoir liés à des problématiques
anxieuse et dépressive
les consultations au centre médico
psychologique ou directement en
établissement psychiatrique doivent
demeurer ouverte sans obligation de
présentation de passes sanitaires il
s'agit d'un impératif de santé publique
qui dépasse ici largement le cadre de la
contamination qu'ovide 19
c'est le sens de notre amendement qui
propose d'exclure les soins
psychiatriques et psychologiques
de l'obligation de présentation d'un
pass sanitaire je vous remercie le 26
vous continuez madame à pour ce nom
madame brûlant merci madame la
présidente le texte de l'assemblée
nationale prévoyait que les mineurs âgés
de 12 à 15 ans seraient soumis au pass
sanitaires pour les activités de loisirs
réalisé dans le cadre des sorties
scolaires ou relevant du périscolaire et
aux passes vaccinale pour les autres
activités de loisirs une usine à gaz
confuse voire hypocrite
lorsque l'on sait que de nombreuses
sorties et activités scolaires ont été
annulés en raison du regain de
l'épidémie que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui tout cela sans que la
justification sanitaire de ces
dispositions soient clairement établies
comme le souligne le rapport de la
commission de lois qui a donc supprimé
l'obligation de passes vaccinale pour
les mineurs toutefois nous souhaitons
aller plus loin et exclure clairement
les mineurs de moins de 18 ans de tout
tout obligations de présentation d'un
pass vaccinale c'est le sens de notre
amendement je vous remercie 125 matchs à
st
madame la présidente je me mets mes
chers collègues pendant les fêtes de
noël et avec la prolifération
très importante du variant et au micro
nous avons vu des familles qui sont
venus voir leurs parents vaccinés qui
les ont contaminé même s'il veut
visiteurs bien sûr été vaccinées
heureusement les personnes vaccinées
même si elles sont hachés mais en bon
état général mais bon pas avoir de
formes graves et vous savez ça a été dit
tout à l'heure on dix ou quinze fois
moins de
deux malheurs de chances d'aller en
soins critiques et nous savons que
certaines personnes très âgées
dépendantes peuvent être aussi contaminé
et avoir des difficultés par exemple
des personnes qui ont une insuffisance
respiratoire peuvent dès qu'on pense et
je répète bien la vaccination empêche
les formes g mais pour des personnes en
très mauvais état général et c'est le
cas souvent en ehpad il peut y avoir des
difficultés photos de mes chers
collègues éviter de contaminer les
personnes en ehpad et nous savons
maintenant que les personnes vaccinées
qui viennent rendre visite peut
effectivement contaminés sans le savoir
parce que eux-mêmes peuvent être
asymptomatique le vaccin diminue mais ne
supprime pas la contagion c'est pour
cela que je conseille dans cet
amendement un test de moins de 24 heures
avant la visite en ehpad vous savez
combien est contagieux donc le loup
micron et vous savez aussi combien un
cluster en ehpad et tendre angoissante
pour les gestionnaires et les soignants
donc je vous demande de réfléchir un
petit peu à cet amendement merci
merci madame la présidente cet
amendement a pour objectif de ne pas se
baser uniquement sur non pardon de se
baser uniquement sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations liées à la cog hill
19 et de ne pas cumuler ce critère avec
un critère de schéma vaccinal complet ou
de circulation active du virus en effet
une circulation active ou une faible
couverture vaccinale n'entraîne pas
corrélativement une hausse des
hospitalisations proportionnelle c'est
le cas aujourd'hui avec le vario micron
tient à affecter un très grand nombre
d'individus puisqu'on dénombre pas moins
de 300 milles contamination par jour y
compris des personnes disposant d'un
schéma vaccinal complet mais qui fort
heureusement se révèle moins dangereux
que d'autres variantes le 121 monsieur
bénard of
madame la présidente l'accès des
médiathèques et soumis à la présentation
de pas salutaire depuis le mois d'août y
compris pour les personnes âgées de plus
de douze heures donc y compris les
jeunes entre 12 et 18 ans cette
disposition nous paraît tout à fait
déséquilibrer les bibliothèques et les
médiathèques
ce sont des lieux d'échangés de lien
social ces lieux participe de
l'apprentissage et de l'éducation de nos
enfants et adolescents dans le cas où
les gestes barrières sont respectés dans
ces établissements il n'est nullement
besoin de conditionner leur accès pour
les jeunes de moins de 18 ans à la
présentation de passe-temps vaccinale
que sanitaire cette proposition vise
donc à protéger l'ensemble des enfants
des adolescents qui subissent de plein
fouet les conséquences économiques et
sociales de la pandémie de kovy 19
rectifié bis monsieur 16
présente monsieur le ministre l'article
premier du projet de loi introduit la
possibilité pour le personnel ou le
responsable du lieu d'un événement ou
d'établissement de contrôler l'identité
des titulaires du pass en cas de doute
par la production d'un document officiel
d'identité ce contrôle d'identité risque
de mettre le gérant d'un établissement
ou d'un événement en situation délicate
dès lors qu'ils ne disposent pas de
motifs impérieux réel où une délégation
de police ont contrôlé l'identité d'un
client ou d'un visiteur
la photo du titulaire du pass
répondant aux normes de production
biométrique permettrait de garantir la
titularité de l'authenticité de
l'attestation tout en facilitant la
gestion des flux et les entrées pour les
exploitants la photo réalisée en selphy
comportant de vraies risque de fraude sa
production devrait répondre aux normes
biométriques iso et être réalisé dans
les conditions prévues par l'article 16
de la loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour la performance de la
sécurité intérieure
les conditions permettant de sécuriser
et faciliter l'identification du
titulaires du pass et d'éviter son
contrôle d'identité sont l'essence de ma
proposition qui se veut pragmatique et
efficace
merci nous prenons maintenant quatre
amendements identiques on commence avec
le 80 me madame me niet merci madame la
présidente au regard des atteintes
portées à l'exercice des droits et
libertés le renvoi des modalités
d'application du mécanisme du pass
vaccinale renforcer un décret simple
n'est pas acceptable en conséquence il
est proposé de supprimer cette
disposition
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
alerter sur les nombreux renvois au
pouvoir réglementaire des mesures
complémentaires au pass vaccinale
contraignante pour la population et
reste régnante pour l'exercice des
libertés
tel est le cas de la détermination des
situations qui exigerait un pass
vaccinale renforcer figurant à l'alinéa
19 de l'article premier de ce présent
projet ce mécanisme s'inspire de ce qui
existe en allemagne mais aussi en
autriche et en suisse et il risque de
s'appliquer prochainement puisque le
gouvernement l'envisagent par voie
réglementaire mais il ne peut être mis
en explications en application sans être
entouré d'un minimum de critères qui
permettront d'en contrôler l'application
or on constate dans la rédaction
actuelle que le seul critère
d'application est trop vague et assez
flou en dépit des tentatives
d'amélioration rédactionnelle introduite
par le rapporteur de la commission des
lois cette disposition ne peut être
maintenu en l'état c'est l'objet de cet
amendement monsieur benarroch
le présent amendement pour objet de
supprimer la possibilité donnée au
gouvernement de prendre par décret la
présentation d'un cumul de justificatifs
passe vaccinale et test de dépistage
négatif pour accéder à certains lieux
nous apparaître disproportionné de
décider par voie réglementaire d'une
restriction supplémentaire pour l'accès
à certains lieux se passe plus nous
paraît incongru dans ce texte nous
vivons aujourd'hui des records de
contamination sans que le gouvernement
n'ait jugé nécessaire dès début décembre
de prendre des mesures de freinage comme
préconisé par le conseil scientifique
préférant laisser courir le virus par
exemple ça a été dit pour sauver noël et
là vous nous demandez aujourd'hui en
plus du pack sinal de laisser la
possibilité au gouvernement par décret
et de demander la présentation d'un
autre justificatif comme un test négatif
par exemple je constate donc que les
désirs de contrôler la propagation sotra
géométrie variés pas de ffp2 pour le
personnel au contact des enfants par
exemple aucune mesure de qualité de
l'air dans les transports du quotidien
autre exemple mais la possibilité de se
passe plus pour un certain nombre
d'activités nous refusons de laisser
encore la bride au gouvernement pour
décider seul de telles restrictions dans
la proportionnalité reste encore à
démontrer
il défend il est défendu il a été bien
défendus par vos collègues madame
131 identique aux deux précédents et au
suivant mais je vous avais la parole
madame cohen
dont je le défends car
cet amendement vise à supprimer la
possibilité d'exiger la présentation
cumulé d'un justificatif de ce tube
vaccinale et d'un test négatif cette
possibilité est en effet prévue à
l'article 1er de ce projet de loi qui
confie le soin à décret de définir le
champ d'application des activités
relevant de cette double présentation
le gouvernement envisage ainsi de se
réserver sans contrôle du parlement la
possibilité d'exiger un cumul de
justificatifs lorsque l'intérêt de la
santé publique et l'état de la situation
sanitaire l'exigent un cas de figure qui
laisse donc une très grande marge
d'appréciation à l'exécutif nous aurions
préféré que ces cas de figure soit
précisément énoncés dans ce projet de
loi monsieur vers en a par exemple cité
le cas des discothèques lors de son
audition devant la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale
mais que savons-nous du champ
d'application qui sera in fine est ainsi
défini nous refusons cet excès de
pouvoir réglementaire et nous souhaitons
supprimer cette disposition qui à notre
sens prive le parlement de ses pouvoirs
par ailleurs si vous voulez si l'esprit
de votre texte favoriser la vaccination
il faut effectivement lui donner du
crédit et du sens et nous pensons qu
effectivement cette cette vaccination a
tout son sens mais il convient donc de
démontrer à celles et à ceux qui ont
fait le parcours vaccinale comme vous le
souhaitez ma qu'ils ont effectivement un
bonus et non pas besoin dans certaines
conditions d'un test supplémentaire nous
appelons donc à un peu de cohérence la
part du gouvernement et la suppression
de ce contrôle renforcé qui brouillent
le message sonne comme un aveu un peu
d'impuissance en quelque sorte du pass
vaccinale à
parvenir à endiguer l'épidémie et
décribilise pour 1 101 morts bon un
passage la parole de l'état
madame benbassa
merci madame la présidente cet alinéa
est révélateur de la fébrilité qui
caractérise ce texte alors que le post
vaccinale est presque présentée comme la
solution miracle à la crise sanitaire
par le gouvernement ce dernier vient
d'introduire la possibilité de mettre en
place par décret des mesures
restrictives
complémentaires ainsi en fonction de
l'appréciation de la situation sanitaire
l'exécutif pourra exiger par décret en
plus de la présentation d'un schéma
vaccinal contre hull et la présentation
de résultats de tests de dépistage
négative pour accéder à certains lieux
dans le dernier avis relatives à ce
projet de loi la défenseure des droits
se dit particulièrement inquiète du
renvoi au pouvoir réglementaire de
l'adoption de mesures complémentaires
contraignante pour la population elle
ajoute à justice qu'il appartient aux
seuls législateur d'adopter ces mesures
est de les encadrer
j'estime qu'il est indispensable pour la
représentation nationale de débats si
davantage de mesures contraignantes
doivent être envisagées en cas de
dégradation de la situation
j'ajoute à cela que conditionner de
nouveau l'accès de certains lieux à la
présentation d'un test négatif serait
synonyme d'échec de la stratégie du post
vaccinales un débat serait alors
nécessaire pour le voir en profondeur de
la stratégie autoritaire et contraignant
que développe le gouvernement depuis
près de deux ans je demande donc la
suppression de cet alinéa mère madame
berthet boys band 173
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues j'ai souhaité
déposer cet amendement qui vise à sortir
au pass sanitaires et vaccinales une
photographie du titulaire répondant aux
normes biométriques
car c'est une attente forte du secteur
des cafetiers hôteliers restaurateurs et
d'une façon plus générale d'une grande
majorité de responsables
d'établissements recevant du public si
l'on peut penser un certain délai pour
sa mise en oeuvre l'acceptation du
contrôle des passants serait pourtant
bien renforcée tant pour les exploitants
qui n'auraient plus à exiger de leurs
clients la présentation d'un deuxième
document que pour les clients eux-mêmes
qui verrait cette opération simplifier
cette proposition présente donc une
simplification pour tous dans la mise en
oeuvre des passes sanitaires et
vaccinales ses deux enfants 17 rectifié
monsieur decool monsieur ça st
la présidente mes chers collègues donc
d'amendements de mon collègue dany
wattebled comme celui de madame berthet
se propose de lutter contre
l'utilisation ne faut pas sous
utilisation de ceux d'autrui
cette pratique donc nuit à un
propagation nuit à la lutte contre la
propagation du colis ce qui est
l'objectif du ps sanitaire et du pass
vaccinale se présente à mam a donc pour
objet de joanes comme ça vient d'être
dit la photo que des photocopies des
entités au pass vaccinale permettant
ainsi de prévenir des fraudes tout en
conservant fièrement la possibilité de
procéder à un contrôle de concordance
documentaire en cas de doute sur l'autre
camp site sur l'authenticité du document
ainsi l'inclusion d'une photographie
d'identité a été légitimement réclamer
par les acteurs du secteur de la
restauration d'hôtellerie pour faciliter
leurs missions de contrôle merci merci
nous allons maintenant prendre 10
amendements identiques si vous trouvez
que l'un aura un orateur avant vous l'a
très bien présente et n'hésitez pas à
dire qu'il est défendu je ne commence
avec le set rectifié bis
tendez oui merci madame la présidente
cet amendement vise à supprimer les
dispositions relatives à la vérification
d'identité lors de la présentation du
futur passe vaccinale si la fraudeuse
ces documents sur ces documents doit
être sévèrement combattu et punis ces
dispositions viennent renforcer le
sentiment de défiance à l'égard des
français la pratique du contrôle
d'identité ou de la vérification de la
concordance d'identité est strictement
encadrée dans notre droit dans une
logique de protection des libertés
individuelles et repose principalement
sur les forces de l'ordre formés à cet
effet le régime de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire actuellement en
vigueur ne justifie pas d'étendre cette
vérification
pour ces deux motifs il convient de
laisser cette tâche aux autorités dont
c'est le métier les forces de l'ordre
merci
on continue avec madame et leur moral
des
défendu
on
continue avec madame après monsieur
fabien gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur vis
mes chers collègues on rentre dans un
moment important
sur la question du contrôle
nous l'avions dit sur la question du
pass annie terre nous avions redis notre
opposition et il y avait déjà la
question
d'y ajouter une pièce d'identité et nous
l'avions dit à cette époque là
nous pensons pas que tout le monde doit
contrôler tout le monde et que demain
nous devions non une société de contrôle
social
où chacune et chacun qui n'est pas
habilité à contrôler les papiers
puissent le faire c'est à dire nous
allons étendre que les serveurs à les
serveuses puisse contrôler les agents de
sécurité qui le soir même agent de
sécurité vont contrôler les serveuses et
les serveurs qui vont se rendre à un
événement ou à tel concert ou un tel
stade pour aller revoir une compétition
sportive on est franchement on nous
voulons pas mettre le doigt là dedans si
nous mettons le doigt là dedans nous
aurons les plus grandes difficultés pour
revenir en arrière donc nous pensons et
nous continuons à penser qu'il faut que
ça soit les op j qui reste et qui puisse
contrôler y compris il ya un débat sur
quelle pièce d'identité parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas obligé de
présenter pièce d'identité avec photo y
compris
quelqu'un qui est avec vous peut
attester que c'est bien vous sur
l'honneur et ça fonctionne et si nous
mettons le doigt là dedans y compris
dans un doute raisonnable
je vous le dis allons nous pensons dans
une autre société et ça ça nous
permettra pas de combattre efficacement
le coc vide c'est tout autre chose comme
projet de société qui nous est proposée
par le gouvernement donc nous proposons
de évidemment de supprimer ces alinéas
je vous remercie madame noël il est
défendu
monsieur qu'est né veut
merci madame la présidente de cheminée
shackley quelques mots simplement pour
dire que ce débat dépasse bien sûr les
clivages politiques et puis suffit de se
rendre dans les établissements de
restauration pour se rendre compte
combien les tenanciers de ces
établissements ne souhaite pas
effectivement qu' il soit obligé
d'opérer des contrôles je crois que cela
relève de la responsabilité défense de
l'ordre et la rédaction des lequel a été
prévu dans le texte paraît suffisamment
flou pour justement pouvoir induire des
abus et donc ceci n'est pas acceptable
et donc il convient je crois de remettre
les choses en place c'est-à-dire de
considérer que les contrôles relève des
restes de la responsabilité des forces
de l'ordre et pas de celle des
exploitantes d'activités commerciales
merci maintenant la présidente monsieur
le ministre sur collègues c'est un
amendement important qui est identique
avec beaucoup d'autres et qui vient bien
rappeler ce qu'est le pass sanitaire
dans son caractère
proportionné est temporaire quand
j'entends qu'un certain nombre de nos
collègues ont l'idée date d'insérer la
photo d'identité dans le passât ni terre
c'est bien qu'ils imaginent que ce pas
sanitaire durera longtemps parce que sur
un plan technique sans aucun avis de la
cnil allait proposer que la photo
d'identité un teg facilité c'est
quasiment faire du pass à l'état en
lui-même une pièce d'identité et donc ça
c'est une grave erreur de mon point de
vue et nous ne devons pas
le passé était déjà suffisamment
attentatoire aux libertés publiques
j'ai l'impression de me répéter mais
c'est bien ce que je pense pour que nous
le laissions au moins dans sa formule
actuelle y compris dans sa version pas
actional sidi si d'aventuré le parlement
devait voter ça mais de ne pas en
rajouter de chose est sûre la question
du contrôle de l'identité on va donner
cette faculté à des responsables
d'établissements mais non seulement on
va leur donner cette faculté au garden
est aussi un pouvoir d'appréciation
c'est quand ils se diront d'eux mêmes
que ils vont elles peut-être dans une
situation
où ils vont devoir appeler à justifier
qu'il vous faire cette démarche là or en
france a été rappelé très bien par
plusieurs orateurs à l'instant ce sont
des personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
jouissant de prérogatives de puissance
publique forme est inscrit dans une
hiérarchie avec un pouvoir disciplinaire
voire de bouvent exposés au changement
de la justice qui font des contrôles
d'identité en france ils ont un
matricule sur le sur le sur le sur
l'épaule et si vous n'êtes pas contents
d'un contrôle d'identité en france on
pouvait vous en plaindre et donc ça
c'est essentiel comment vous dire que de
recourir et vous exercez demain
vis-à-vis d'un tenancier de bars ou des
restaurants qui vous empêchera de
rentrer donc vraiment supprimant ce
contrôle d'identité qui est une très
mauvaise idée mais ses soeurs
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai dit
hier tout à l'heure dans la discussion
générale
combien cette question était importante
pour notre groupe
nous avons dit qu'il était dans la
logique de l'obligation vaccinale
2e
respecter le pass
vaccinale en dépit du fait que nous
aurions préféré que notre amendement sur
l'obligation vaccinale fut adoptée
nous avons dit qu'il y avait pour nous
des conditions fortes en termes de
libertés publiques et c'est pourquoi je
ne vais pas développer mais l'argument
est très fort quand je vois qu'il est
dit que le restaurateur en question
devra statuer pour savoir s'il existe
des raisons sérieuses de penser
comment va-t-il penser en regardant le
visage l'apparence d'une personne qui
est là il va falloir quand même lui
demander ses papiers d'identité
cependant qu'une autre ne suscitera pas
la même suspicion
il y a un gros problème et je crois même
un problème constitutionnel
mes chers collègues j'ai observé que
monsieur le rapporteur philippe bas
avait été constant dans ses
appréciations et dans ses convictions
sur l'ensemble des sujets entre hier et
aujourd'hui sauf sur ce sujet ou son
appréciation à évoluer et j'espère de
tout coeur que ce lara que cela nous
permettra d'avoir une position très
claire sur la répartition des rôles
entre des commerçants restaurateurs etc
et les forces de police et de
gendarmerie que chacun accomplisse son
office monsieur benarroch
si mes collègues d'avoir brillamment
défendu ces amendements identiques est
similaire
cette mesure en elle-même porte le
principe d'un contrôle d'identité
réalisés par des personnes non
habilitées à le faire et qui plus est
qui ne souhaite pas effectuer ces
contrôles en leur laissant plus une
livre appréciation à leur discrétion
totale des critères selon lesquels ils
pourraient ou pas contrôler ses papiers
cette mesure en fait participe de fait à
l'instauration d'un contrôle social
généralisé de la population de
l'installation d'un nouveau modèle
social et d'un nouveau modèle de société
qui est contraire aux valeurs de
beaucoup d'entre nous qui est contraire
aux valeurs de notre démocratie et qui
est contraire aussi aux valeurs de notre
groupe elf eu enfin aussi nous ne
l'avons pas dit par son principe même
par la façon dont la le pouvoir
discrétionnaire et donner à certains qui
ne le souhaitent pas d'ailleurs conduire
à des phénomènes de violence de trouble
de l'ordre public et à un certain nombre
d'incivilités qui peuvent devenir assez
grave donc nous vous demandons
sincèrement de bien vouloir accepter de
considérer les arguments des différents
intervenants et de bien vouloir voter
ces amendements de telle façon à ce que
nous n'allions pas vers une dérive
de notre constitution l'amour est
erronée il est défendu madame benbassa
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues les règles
définissant le cadre d'un contrôle
d'identité sont établis par l'article
78-2 du code pénal seuls les officiers
agents et agentes joints de police
judiciaire peuvent le réaliser or la
viabilité du pass vaccinale dépend
grandement de son contrôle le texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
permettez d'octroyer aux personnes en
charge de ce contrôle le droit
d'effectuer non pas un contrôle
d'identité
mais je suis une vérification de
concordance documentaire si cette astuce
lexical n'a pas été conservé par la
commission des lois du sénat le
dispositif proposé par celle ci reste
tout de même problématique le texte est
toujours la possibilité aux personnes
chargées du contrôle du pass vaccinale
d'effectuer un contrôle d'identité
ce transfert de compétence de la police
de la société civile n'est pas
acceptable comment se prémunir de
possibles discriminations
comment éviter les abus volontaire ou
non de la part de ceux qui doivent
contrôler une grande majorité d'entre
eux n'est ni formés ni qualifiés pour
cela ajoutons à cela que l'aspect
chronophage d'un tel contrôle plus que
le simple scan d'un qr code peut rendre
ce contrôle d'identité difficile à
réaliser dans certains établissements
cette question du contrôle de l'identité
ne semble être qu'un détail dans le
débat pour le gouvernement cela ne l'est
pas pour beaucoup de nos concitoyennes
et concitoyens qui souffrent
quotidiennement des abus liés à cette
procédure c'est aussi pour cela que je
demande sa suppression mairie
merci madame benbassa nous en avons donc
fini avec ces amendements identiques le
153 monsieur guay je crois merci au
président une minute dernier argument
cher collègue
vous savez combien il faut de temps pour
former un officier de police judiciaire
ces 18 mois pourquoi
parce que la police
c'est les seuls à qui nous confions la
violence légitime de l'état et nous
l'acceptons parce qu'un contrat social
c'est les seuls qui peuvent nous
contraindre nous arrêtent et nous
demandait le papier dix huit mois de
formation d'ailleurs nous avons un débat
entre nous il faudrait l'augmenter cette
formation de nos policiers et nos
policière et formé plus au pgi qui
manque dans nos commissariats temps
aujourd'hui mais si demain si demain
nous votons ça nous permettant à chacune
et chacun en l'espace d'une nuit de
devenir officier de police judiciaire et
de pouvoir contrôler tout le monde
mais imaginez un seul instant qu'elle
manque de discernement parce
qu'évidemment certains le feront bien
mais nous allons donner un petit pouvoir
sans formation à des centaines de
milliers de personnes et ce sont des
abus qui va voir mais ce sont aussi les
mettre en pra dans les difficultés parce
qu'ils ne seront pas formés à pouvoir
faire ce contrôle en toute sécurité
mais oui vous pouvez le dire mais si la
personne refuse de s'y soumettre parce
qu'il ya un doute légitime qu'est ce qui
va se passer on va faire peser sa sur
nos restaurateurs sont les agents de
sécurité de tels événements donc prenons
bien attention et je redis
si nous mettons le doigt là dedans nous
aurons la plus grande difficulté à la
sortie la gestion de la crise sanitaire
de pouvoir en sortir et de retirer ce
droit acquis nous l'avons confié un soir
en plein milieu de semaine je vous
remercie
merci monsieur richard 983 rectifié
en peu de mots il nous semble que le
dispositif qui permet simplement de
vérifier s'il y a bien concordance entre
les mots le nom et la date de naissance
d'un personnes qui sur un pass vaccinale
est la pièce d'identité se suffit à elle
même et que ce n'est pas une bonne idée
monsieur le rapporteur de vouloir
introduire la compo la comparaison avec
d'autres pièces parce que la carte
d'identité ou passeport naturellement il
a une photo récente et une faute aux
normes et il a une date de naissance il
me semble donc que d'aller chercher
d'autres documents qu'ils soient n'ont
pas la date de naissance sont des photos
qui sont hors des normes qui peuvent
être qu'ils peuvent dater de 25 ans et
n'est pas une n'est pas un avantage il
vaut mieux s'en tenir à mon avis au
président entités officiels
merci monsieur richard nous allons
maintenant donner la parole aux
rapporteurs pour qu'il nous donne son
avis sur tous ses amendements
madame la présidente mon avis celui
plutôt de la commission des lois sur
l'amendement 178 est le même que son
avis sur le 189 de monsieur ravier car
tous deux fixe un âge en deçà duquel on
ne demanderait que le pass vaccinale et
au delà duquel on pourrait demander non
en deçà duquel on ne demanderait que
parce sanitaires et au delà duquel on
pourrait demander le pass vaccinale je
voudrais dire que le critère d'âge qui
soit fixe à 40 ou 50 ans n'est
probablement pas pertinent sur le plan
médical car ça n'est pas ni 50 ni 40 un
tournant significatif
dans le risque sanitaire ça ne prend pas
en compte les critères de comorbidité
qui peuvent justifier une attention
particulière pour une partie de la
population exposée à un risque plus
grand que les autres et puis enfin et ce
n'est pas un détail c'est quand même
très difficile a impliqué dans les cafés
et les restaurants quand on voit arriver
un client de se demander si la cac 25
ans 44 ans 39 52 et ceci est donc une
source de complexité c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons émis un avis
défavorable à ces deux amendements nous
avons également émis un avis défavorable
à l'amendement
184 rectifié de monsieur richard
puisqu'il rétabli en réalité le
dispositif que nous avons voulu modifier
qui était proposée par le gouvernement
s'agissant maintenant de l'amendement
numéro
56 rectifié bis
c'est un des amendements d'une catégorie
qu'on pourrait qualifier catégorie de
l'effeuillage de l'artichaut du pass
vaccinale autrement dit on retirerait
secteur d'activité par secteur
d'activité feuille à feuille tout
ou une grande partie des lieux où le
passé axe inhalent serait exigée et puis
finalement si on adoptait toute cette
série d'amendements on se rendrait
compte qu'il ya plus de passes vaccinale
ou à peu de choses près c'est le bien
sûr le danger le risque sanitaire qui
doit être pris en compte et non pas la
nature des lieux sportifs culturels
commercial qui doivent l'être et donc
l'amendement numéro 56 rectifié bis pour
cette raison puisque il vise seulement
les lieux de culture et d'établissements
qui seraient les habits sont culturelles
qui seraient
exonérés de la présentation du pass
sanitaires a reçu un avis défavorable
même chose pour l'amendement suivant le
57 puisque lui s'intéresse aux activités
sportives qui seraient exonérés de la
présentation d'un pass vaccinale c'est
encore une fois le danger qui compte
avis défavorable avis également
défavorable à l'amendement qui va au
delà des souplesses pourtant très grande
que la commission des lois décidé
d'apporter s'agissant des exigences
s'imposant aux mineurs de 18 ans ils ont
créé un système 5 qui est d'ailleurs
déjà en vigueur pas sanitaire seulement
en dessous de 18 ans pour les
différentes sorties de ces jeunes et
passe vaccinale au delà et cet
amendement propose de supprimer aussi le
pass sanitaires pour les mineurs je
tiens quand même à souligner que le il y
à une
exigence de sécurité sanitaire pour eux
aussi à ce que on applique au moins le
pass sanitaires sans exagérer dans les
exigences qui leur sont imposées suit un
amendement qui est assez
intéressant parce que plusieurs de nos
collègues on présentait peu ou prou le
même amendement c'est un amendement 272
rectifié qui a reçu un avis défavorable
aussi et qui imposeraient que le pass
sanitaire soit assortie d'une
photographie d'identité et dans un
premier temps j'aurais volontiers donné
un avis favorable à ce type
d'amendements mais on ne peut pas le
faire d'abord pour la raison très
judicieuse indiqué par notre collègue
les loïc hervé qui représente le sénat à
la commission nationale de
l'informatique liberté mais la
photographie c'est une donnée sensible
et encore faudrait-il d'ailleurs définir
quelle est la nature de la photographie
qui pourraient figurer sur le poste
sanitaire mais au delà de ce problème de
droit pur il ya une autre question qui
n'est pas moins importante c'est le
caractère opérationnel de la mesure car
si on pouvait d'un claquement de doigts
faire en sorte que pour 53 millions de
français déjà vaccinées
qui détiennent le pass sanitaire au
titre de cette vaccination on pouvait
modifier sur un serveur qui n'a pas été
dimensionnée pour cela les prescriptions
pour prendre en compte une photo qui
vous le savez bien en matière
informatique est quelque chose de lourd
c'est à dire qui prend de la place dans
les réseaux qui sont utilisés en réalité
si on adopté cet amendement qui paraît
un amendement de bon sens on arriverait
un résultat paradoxal c'est que le pass
sanitaires et le pass vaccinale serait
suspendue pendant des semaines et
peut-être même pendant des mois c'est à
dire pendant une période au delà de
laquelle le pass ne serait plus
nécessaire donc je crois pour cette
raison de faisabilité et pour la raison
de droit qui consiste à protéger les
données sensibles on ne peut pas
accepter cet amendement quelle que soit
la tentation qu'on pourrait avoir j'ai
obligé je le regrette je regardais tout
à l'heure notre collègue le président
milon qui était très déçu de mon propos
est évidemment je comprends pourquoi
parce qu'il s'applique aussi à son
amendement numéro 60 mais encore une
fois ça n'est pas
l'intention portés par cet amendement
qui simplifierait tous nos problèmes de
contrôle de l'identité évidemment des
détenteurs qui motivent ma
la position négative de la commission ce
sont les arguments que j'ai
énoncé et qui je crois ne sont pas
insurmontables si on avait pu prévoir
quelques années à l'avance on aurait un
jour à mettre en place un pass
sanitaires on aurait pu lever sans doute
ces deux objections nous arrivons à
l'amendement numéro 120 qui propose de
maintenir un pass sanitaires pour
l'accès aux transports publics régionaux
inter régionaux alors cet amendement est
contraire à la position de la commission
vous savez que nous avons
accepté ce pass vaccinale pour les
déplacements de longue distance
par transports publics inter régionaux
mais il ya heureusement ce qui devrait
peut-être satisfaire les objectifs des
auteurs de cet amendement
des exceptions à l'exigence du pass le
texte prévoit qu'en cas d'urgence aucun
justificatif ne peut être exigée ont
plus en cas d'urgence se déplacer et le
texte prévoit aussi qu'il ya des motifs
impérieux d'autres familiales ou de
santé auxquels nous avons ajouté les
motifs impérieux d'ordre professionnel
en commission des lois qui permettent de
voyager
simplement avec un test de dépistage
négatif c'est à dire en réalité qui
rétablit pour ses transports le pass
sanitaires sans imposer le pass
vaccinale quand il y a ce motif
impérieux il suffit pour ça si vous avez
un motif impérieux de faire le test
d'avoir le certificat avec son qr code
vous le présenter au contrôleur de la
sncf et il ne peut pas vous sanctionnez
d'avoir pris le train vous avez
maintenant le 43 avec donc avis
défavorable le 43 rectifié terre pour
les mêmes motifs
l'avis est défavorable quant aux
soixante dix huit puisqu'il porte sur le
même sujet la vie est aussi
défavorable
s'agissant du 190e rectifier c'est
encore le même sujet et la vie est
encore
défavorable pour le 126
la vie est également défavorable car il
s'agit de là même qui tion des
transports et alors là nous avons un
amendement le 127 qui je dois dire à une
rédaction qui mérite d'être amélioré
mais je ne voudrais pas que vous soyez
retenue dans un élan du coeur en faveur
de cet amendement en raison de cette
rédaction insuffisante que je n'ai pas
pu redresser avec ses auteurs mais que
je m'engage s'il était adopté à modifier
dans le cadre des discussions en
commission mixte paritaire il s'agit de
cet amendement numéro 127 qui prévoit
d'ajouter aux motifs
impérieux d'ordre familial de santé ou
professionnels un motif qu'ils seraient
la présentation du voyageur devant une
juridiction où le fait de asud d'assurer
les droits de sa défense en allant voir
son avocat je crois que c'est une bonne
idée que nos collègues du groupe
communiste on tue d'ajouter cette
possibilité de se déplacer avec un test
négatif sans vaccination si c'est pour
un motif de cette nature donc mon avis
favorable mais je tiens quand même au
codis il il faudra le modifier parce que
il ya un tout petit tout petit faiblesse
de rédaction m'a-t-on dit le juge moi
même qu'il faudrait corriger nous avons
un amendement numéro 79 19 qui
voudraient ajouter au motif
professionnel pour lequel on peut
voyager juste avec un test négatif la
formation nous considérons que la
formation rentre dans le motif d'ordre
professionnel et que cette précision
n'est donc pas nécessaire n'offrez pas
un drame si vous l'adoptez quand même
nous avons maintenant le 46 rectifié
quater sur la durée de validité des
tests de dépistage virologique les
auteurs de cet amendement madame noël et
plusieurs de nos autres collègues
considèrent qu' on est passé de 72
heures à 24 heures par une mesure
d'ordre administratives et voudrait
qu'on nérigean dispositions législatives
la durée de validité des tests pour le
rétablir dans la durée de 72 heures la
commission souhaite s'en remettre à la
sagesse de notre assemblée sur ce point
l'amendement 157 veut supprimer la
possibilité d'imposer un pass sanitaires
pour l'accès aux établissements de santé
sociaux et médico-sociaux l'avis est
défavorable
le 47 rectifié bis est également
contraire à la position de la commission
la vie est également défavorable
le deux sans trois c'est le mien j'ai
déjà dit que c'était un amendement de
coordination le 159 de madame assassiné
de plusieurs de ses collègues vise à
faciliter l'accès aux soins
psychiatriques et psychologiques
pour mieux protéger les personnes
vulnérables
et je voudrais dire que cet amendement
n'est pas nécessaire en réalité parce
qu'il existe déjà une exception en cas
d'urgence pour l'accès à ces
établissements dont et personne pour
être soigné même si elles ne sont pas
vaccinés quant à l'amendement numéro 26
supprime la possibilité de maintenir le
pass sanitaires pour les mineurs c'est
donc contraire à la position de la
commission l'avis est défavorable
le numéro 125 rectifié prévoit qu' il
faut présenter un test négatif pour
l'accès aux établissements et les
services sociaux et médico-sociaux notre
collègue monsieur chassaing l'a fort
bien présenter tout à l'heure en
expliquant qu'il fallait ajouter à la
protection liés à la vaccination
une protection dans l'intérêt des
pensionnaires qui serait une protection
liée à un test négatif donc on
cumulerait
le pass vaccinale plus le test négatif
comme dans les discothèques mais nous
avons considéré que en dépit de
l'intérêt du point de vue de l'épidémie
et de la protection contre l'épidémie
des résidents de ces établissements il
fallait aussi prendre en compte la
nécessité des visites et que malgré tout
si ces personnes sont vaccinées que
leurs visiteurs sont aussi vacciner on
peut quand même considérer que la
protection est bonne rien n'est pire
pour nos personnes âgées deux en avons
dans nos propres familles et nous le
savons parce que nous l'avons
personnellement expérimenté que cette
solitude qui vous gagne alors que votre
univers amicale s'est dégarni peu à peu
qu'il ne reste plus que quelques membres
de votre famille si en plus ils ne
peuvent pas vous rendre visite c'est
vraiment terrible alors nous avons donné
un avis défavorable je m'en excuse
auprès de notre collègue pour ces
raisons l'amendement 50 rectifié quater
nous ramène à un débat que nous avons
déjà eu sur les critères d'extinction du
pass vaccinale la vie est forcément eu
négatif et je dois dire que compte tenu
du vote que vous avez fait sur les
précédents amendements je crois que ça
devrait être le même vote c'est à dire
un vote négatif sur ce point pour
préserver le système de trois critères
qui nous paraît bien cerner la gravité
de la situation
pour justifier
le maintien du pass vaccinale ou au
contraire accepter ou entraîner plutôt
saturant les docteurs pardonnez moi il
est minuit faut que je fasse un petit
bois pendant ce petit point ça va vous
permettre si vous le voulez bien de
rechercher le votre avis sur le 30 sept
rectifiez qui nous a échappé voilà et je
voulais vous prévenir monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues qu'il est
minuit que je vous propose de prolonger
la séance afin de permettre à la
commission et au gouvernement de
présenter leur avis sur les amendements
en discussion commune et peut-être de
commencer les opérations de vote et je
vous propose que notre façon de points à
minuit et demi pour voir si des guides
poursuivre encore un peu au delà de
minuit et demi
si le questeur soeur dit que c'est pas
mal
on devrait pouvoir
nous engager dans cette voie
pas d'autres observations
monsieur le rapporteur le jeu vous rend
la parole merci madame la présidente le
30 sept rectifiez donc c'est un avis
défavorable non pas que nous soyons
défavorable au fond mais c'est parce que
nous avons déjà intégré dans le texte
c'est
exigences il s'agit pour les personnes
qui ont une contre-indication médicale
reconnu valable de pouvoir avoir
l'équivalent du pass vaccinale c'est à
dire qu' il puisse
accéder à tous les lieux auxquels les
détenteurs du pass vaccinale peuvent
accéder aux dames la présidente j'en
suis je crois aux 121
firme hill 121 c'est la même chose c'est
les feuillages de l'artichaut et cette
fois ce n'est plus le sport ou les lieux
culturels en général mais seulement les
médiathèques bibliothèques et musées et
je crois qu'effectivement on doit en
rester à la disposition que nous avons
prises et s'agissant des des jeunes je
rappelle que seul le pass sanitaire est
demandée et non pas le pass vaxy mal
compte tenu du vote de la commission des
lois et de votre propre vote sur cette
base nous avons maintenant l'amendement
numéro 170 rectifié bis et c'est la
question de nouveau de la photographie
qui seraient intégrés sur les
justificatifs de vaccination je fais
donc la même réponse que tout à l'heure
madame berthé a présenté un amendement
numéro 173 sur le même thème sera pas
étonné que je fasse la même réponse et
puis nous passons si vous le voulez bien
un amendement numéro 177 rectifier c'est
toujours le même sujet et c'est toujours
la même réponse nous avons maintenant un
nombre élevé d'amendements identiques
le set rectifié bis le 17 19 le simple
en t1 rectifié terre le 58 le 61 le 71
rectifié bis le 81 le centquatre le 164
rectifié quater et le 168
ces amendements visent à supprimer la
possibilité de la vérification
d'identité même sur les selon les
modalités
allégée par votre commission des lois
nous avons examiné c'est cet amendement
reproduit par plusieurs de nos collègues
de plusieurs groupes et nous avons
décidé d'y donner un avis de sagesse
certes dans un premier temps nous avons
considéré que l'ampleur des fraudes tels
que le gouvernement les a décrites
justifier de facilité dans les lieux
dont l'accès est assujettie à la
présentation du pass sanitaires une
vérification
allégée de la correspondance entre le
pass sanitaire est un élément qui ne
serait pas probant devant une
juridiction
mais qui serait de nature à lever les
doutes tout de même dans la plupart des
cas qui aurait été la présentation
d'une pièce comme le permis de conduire
comme le pass navigo comme la carte
vitale comme une carte d'identité
professionnelle et nous considérions que
ceux ci devaient se faire uniquement
quand un doute évident apparaissait au
responsable de l'accueil dans ces
établissements et qu' il fallait y
mettre une condition importante qui
était l'impossibilité de relever le nom
de la personne suspectée de fraude et
l'interdiction par voie de conséquence
de tout délation et puis j'entends bien
ce débat j'ai essayé de sauver cette
mesure parce qu'il me paraissait quand
même face à la fraude nécessaire d'être
vigilant mais j'entends bien que les
inconvénients paraissent l'emporter sur
les avantages parce que au fond nos
établissements qui
doivent vérifier la détention d'un pass
sanitaire ne vont pas s'engager dans ces
vérifications spontanément même si la
loi leur en donne la permission et
considère et on peut considérer que
c'est à juste titre que ce n'est pas
leur rôle et même si nous l'inscrivons
dans la loi il est quand même doute
qu'on fasse de ces établissements et de
leurs personnels des auxiliaires de la
police du coup j'ai été convaincu que
nous pouvions faire évoluer notre
position je les dis devant la commission
des doigts qui a bien voulu accepter de
s'en remettre sur ces amendements
identiques à votre sagesse en sachant
qu'elle est grande
je passe maintenant à l'amendement
numéro 153 de madame à ça si madame à ça
si je ne veux pas dire de mal de cet
amendement parce qu'en réalité si notre
avis est défavorable c'est parce qu'il
est satisfait
le numéro 183 rectifié a été présentée
par monsieur richard qui s'attend à ma
réponse de toute façon il a des chances
de tomber si les amendements pour
lesquels nous nous en remettons à la
sagesse de l'assemblée devait être
adoptée la vie sinon seraient
défavorables
enfin il y à un amendement de madame
vogel c'est l'amendement numéro 67 il
soulève une problématique sérieuse dont
l'une cessons de parler au fil des
textes que nous discutons sur les
urgences sanitaires et la gestion de la
crise sanitaire une problématique très
sérieuse c'est celle des vaccins qu'ils
ont reçue à l'étranger et pouilly la
conditionnelle dans le il ne séduit pas
cet endroit là de notre discussion il
est plus loin et on l'a pas il n'a pas
été présentée jusqu'à présent je le
regrette j'aurais tenté mais ils
répondent de plus complètement mais je
me réserve pour demain oui mais je suis
pas sûr qu'on s'en rappellent tous donc
en revanche il le manque votre avis sur
le groupe d'amendements identiques 85
bien sûr madame la présidente j'allais
justement y venir
il s'agit de la suppression de la
possibilité pour le gouvernement
d'imposer un cumul du justificatif du
statut vaccinal avec un test négatif la
vie pour le numéro 80 est défavorable et
par voie de conséquence également pour
le sang neuf le 131 et le 169 rectifier
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous pour
le même exercice
national la présidente madame au
dessinateur j'ai essayé d'être le plus
synthétique possible même si
[Musique]
je considère qu'il est
normal et respectueux des six d'apporter
quelques éléments de réponse aux
arguments que vous avez porté au travers
de la défense de vos amendements et
quand bien même je crois que le ministre
à la fois devant la commission dans la
discussion générale et sur les premiers
amendements de suppression a pu d'ores
et déjà apporté quelques
éclaircissements sur ce qu'était la
position du gouvernement alors les
premiers amendements madame la
présidente qui est 178 189 qui vise à
restreindre l'application
à un âge inférieur à celui qui est
aujourd'hui prévue ou en tout cas à même
introduire un critère d'âge en réalité
obtient
des avis défavorable de la part
gouvernement
l'amendement numéro 184 rectifié de
monsieur richard
qui vise à rétablir au dispositif adopté
par l'assemblée nationale concernant
l'application du pass vaccinale au
mineur qui était une des dispositions
que qui était inclus dans l'amendement
numéro 2 200 du gouvernement portait
tout à l'heure par le gouvernement et
qui n'a pas été adopté par cette
assemblée
obtiendra 2 de ce fait un avis favorable
de la part
de vous en doutiez monsieur le sénateur
de la part du gouvernement puisque c'est
un dispositif qui opère une conciliation
équilibrée entre la nécessité de
permettre l'accès des mineurs à des
activités indispensables à leur
développement
je l'évoquais tout à leurs sorties
scolaires périscolaires et
extrascolaires et celle d'un sujet un
dispositif qui soit suffisamment
homogène d'une part protecteur d'autre
part pour leur santé ce qui nous semble
être totalement nécessaire un avis daf
défavorable donc sur cet
amendement tous les amendements suivant
le 56 rectifié bise de même noël 57
rectifié bis également
qui relève de
la stratégie dite de l'effeuillage
de l'artichaut
tout cas la sphère la version du
rapporteur pour les feuillages du moins
pour les feuillages de l'artichaut et
qui vise à exclure l'application du
plaza vaccinale lieu de culture
s'agissant du 56 des activités sportives
s'agissant du 5 août et
reçoivent un avis défavorable de la part
du gouvernement pour les mêmes raisons
que celles exposées par le rapporteur ça
reviendrait petit à petit a vidé de sa
substance
l'existence même est le principe les
bénéfices de cette de ce post vaccinales
avis défavorable donc s'agissant des
amendements numéro
tous les tous les amendements qui visent
à intégrer une photographie dans le pas
à signaler en
conséquence de supprimer la possibilité
pour les exploitants des établissements
qui reçoivent du public d'exiger la
présentation d'un document officiel donc
les 172 rectifier le 60 de monsieur
milon
et puis il y en aura d'autres qui
viendront par la suite avis défavorable
a aussi de la part du gouvernement un
dispositif tel qu'il est prévu
aujourd'hui qui nous semble équilibré je
vous rappelle que le conseil d'état je
ne sais plus si le rapporteur l'a évoqué
mais a estimé qu'il n'y avait aucun
obstacle constitutionnel ou
conventionnelle à prévoir parce que les
exploitants d'établissements recevant du
public puisse exiger la présentation
d'un document officiel pour vous l'avez
compris évidemment lutter contre la
fraude dont on sait qu'elle est massive
et dont vous savez que le gouvernement
en a fait également en fin de la lutte
contre la fraude une priorité ces
dernières semaines
l'amendement 68 rectifié quater de
madame noël revient sur la question du
pass vaccinale ou sanitaire s'agissant
des mineurs et donc pour les mêmes
raisons exposées précédemment ça serait
un avis défavorable
tous les amendements visant ce sera
alors 37 héritiers de monsieur lévy avis
défavorable tous les amendements qui
visent à introduire des dispositifs
particulière concernant les transports
inter régionaux ça concerne le 120 de
monsieur bénard ' le 43 rectifié terre
de madame noël
le 78 de monsieur sueur
qui met huit heures pour venir de
marseille le 126 de madame assassi le
127 de monsieur de madame assassi de la
même façon qui a obtenu de mémoire un
avis favorable sous conditions de
réécriture par le rapporteur mais ça
sera un avis défavorable de la part du
gouvernement de la même façon le 79 qui
concerne l apprentissage
c'est celui de madame sylvie robert
46 de madame noël voilà tous ses
amendements qui concerne les transports
internationaux gouvernement estime que
soient
les les critères que les sénateurs
souhaitent introduire sont déjà inclus
dans le texte et dans le dispositif tel
qu'il est prévu soit il vise à
restreindre le descriptif que prévoit le
gouvernement
qui vise à qui vise à
imposer un certain nombre de garanties
de sécurité dans des lieux qui restent
des lieux où la contamination peut être
élevée et que nous ne souhaitons donc
pas
affaiblir donc avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble de ces amendements sur le 157
nous arrivons à une série d'amendements
sur l'accès aux établissements de santé
commencer par le 157 de madame
assassi suppression du pass sanitaires
pour l'accès aux établissements de santé
rappeler tout d'abord je ne sais plus là
aussi si le rapporteur l'a fait mais que
cette obligation
on parle bien du pass sanitaires et non
pas du pass vaccinale n'a pas été créée
par le présent projet de loi met déjà en
vigueur depuis la loi du 31 mai 2021
cela constitue vous le savez un outil
indispensable nous avons déjà eu ces
débats à l'occasion du vote de la loi
précédente pour protéger les personnes
vulnérables qui se trouvent dans ces
établissements et dont l'état nécessite
précisément une prise en charge
sanitaire ou ou médico-social ces
personnes présentent des risques
importants de contacter une forme grave
de la maladie ça justifie ainsi la mise
en oeuvre de protection à l'égard du
virus je rappelle également que cette
obligation n'est applicable qu'aux
personnes qui accompagnent ou qui
rendent visite aux personnes accueillies
dans ces services de santé et aux
personnes accueillies pour deschamps un
programme et elle ne concerne pas
naturellement
les accès à de tels établissements cas
d'urgence qui sont réservées par le
droit en vigueur et en outre elle
préserve le droit de visite dès lors
qu'un pass sanitaire est présenté et ce
droit de visite et en outre garanti en
cas d'urgence 100 passes ce qui vise
notamment à garantir l'accompagnement
des personnes en fin de vie qui est un
sujet qui a été évoquée par certains
voilà donc là aussi un dispositif qui
n'est pas nouveau qui est équilibré qui
protègent les personnes qui sont qui
sont
accueillis soigner danser dans ces
établissements qui garantit le droit de
visite et qui ne constitue pas une
restriction à l'accès aux soins raison
pour laquelle c'est donc un avis
défavorable sur le 157 sur l'a47
rectifié bis un avis de sagesse sur le
deux sans trois un rendement de
coordination du rapporteur
avis défavorable pour les mêmes raisons
qu évoqué à l'instant sur le 159 de
madame assassi qui lui concerne les
établissements de soins psychiatriques
et psychologiques
nous revenons sur la question des
mineurs avec le l'amendement numéro 26
là aussi ce sera un avis défavorable
pour les raisons que nous avons pu
exposer précédemment
sur le 125 rectifié du sénateur chassang
qui l'a aussi vie à modifier le régime
d'accès aux établissements et services
sociaux et médico sociaux pour les
raisons que j'ai exposé nous voulons
rester sur le système tel que nous
l'avons imaginé jusqu'à jusqu'à présent
sera donc un avis défavorable sur le 125
rectifié
sur le 50 rectifié quater de madame noël
quirky qui porte la hausse si sûr enfin
où de nouveaux plus tôt puisque faisons
quelques allers retours entre les
thématiques de ces différents
amendements en discussion commune qui
revient sur la question des mineurs un
avis défavorable
défavorable également sur le 121 de
monsieur benachenhou revenons sur les
questions des feuillages l'artichaut
puisqu'il s'agit cette fois ci des
établissent des discothèques des musées
des bibliothèques dont vous souhaiteriez
restreinte pour lesquelles vous
souhaiteriez restreindre l'utilisation
du pass sanitaires
sur le cent soixante dix rectifié bis
un avis défavorable
on revient sur la question de la
pièce d'identité et de la photo sur le
pass sanitaires sur la question des idem
pour le 173 de madame berthé qui est sur
le même sujet
177 rectifier de la même façon j'ai
passé les 80 cents 931 et 169 qui eux
portent sur le pass d'i2g plus c'est à
dire la possibilité de cumuler est une
preuve de vaccination via le pacte
d'actionnaires et la réalisation d'un
test négatif récent effectivement dans
certains dans certains lieux dans
certaines circonstances et c'est déjà le
cas ce principe de 2 passes 2 g plus
c'est déjà en oeuvre en réalité
s'agissant des transports internationaux
pour des personnes qui viennent de
certains pays
en zone classée rouge nous exigeons déjà
pour ces voyageurs la présentation
cumulés d'une preuve de vaccination et
d'une preuve d'un test négatif et il est
d'autres circonstances il est d'autres
lieux il est une situation sanitaire qui
pourrait nous amener à effectivement
exigé le cumul de ces deux de ces deux
preuves et c'est la possibilité que nous
souhaitons dont nous souhaitons pouvoir
disposer raison pour laquelle il y a un
avis défavorable du gouvernement sur les
80 cents 931 et 169 rectifié sur la
dizaine d'amendements
7 rectifié biz 17 19 51 rectifié terre
58,71 rectifié bis
81/100 464 rectifié quater et 168
qui visait à supprimer la possibilité
pour les exploitants d'établissements de
procéder à une vérification de
concordance entre l'identité des tentes
en impasse vaccinale ou sanitaires tels
qu'at&t ce n'est pas un document
officiel et données nominatives
figureront sur se passe là aussi un avis
défavorable en ligne et en ligne avec
tout ce que j'ai pu exposer paravent et
avec les arguments que le rapporteur a
également développé avec lequel le
gouvernement est d'accord sur un avis
défavorable
enfin sur le
nom c'est un avis défavorable sur de la
part du gouvernement voilà c'était
sagesse de la part du rapporteur c'est
défavorable de la part du gouvernement
merci
sur les arguments mais effectivement
j'en arrive à une conclusion
un peu un peu plus un peu plusieurs
voilà
je pourrais mais en l'occurrence c'est
le gouvernement émet un avis défavorable
le 153 de manama ça si
c'est un avis défavorable madame la
sénatrice monsieur richard le 183
une proposition de retrait sinon un avis
là aussi défavorable sur la question du
contrôle de concordance d'identité et la
suppression de la nécessité d'une
photographie dans le document qui peut
être présenté pour une personne pour
justifier qu'elle est bien titulaire
légitime du pass
la substitution du test de dépistage
négatif à l'obligation de présenter un
pass vaccinale présenté par madame noël
et qui vise donc là aussi à vider sa
substance le pass vaccinale à nos yeux
reçoit un avis négatif
je continue ma nana président vous me
direz quand il faut quand il faut que je
m'arrête seul ministre arrêté juste j'ai
fini le volant
alors nous allons donc commencer des
opérations de vote sur ces amendements
nous commençons par le 178 carrosse
yonne monsieur janvier vous non nous
consommons en 78 kg a reçu un double
avis défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstenait pas adopté
de 184 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de
la commission est favorable du
gouvernement clé pour quiconque qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopté de 189
double avis défavorable pied pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
le des ou l'eire n'est pas ne suis pas
je sais pas les deux équipes le rapide
que le dérouleur j'en ai conscience oui
mais là c'est compliqué quand même
[Musique]
à
alors on y va
madame coatch pdc bon moi je vois pas le
déroutage c'est bon le 56 rectifié bis
double avis défavorable qui et pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le 57 rectifié biz double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté le 172
rectifié double avis défavorable qui et
pour qui et contre qui savent ce n'est
pas adopté le 60 double avis défavorable
qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas
exceptionnel pas adopter
le 68 rectifié quater double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 37
rectifié double avis défavorable qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté de 120 double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 43 critères double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le 78 double avis défavorable qui
et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 190 rectifié double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 126 double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient et n'est
pas adopté le 127 avis favorable de la
commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
le
79 avec un avis défavorable
du rapporteur
est défavorable du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre qui zappe sien n'est pas
adopté le 46 rectifié terre un avis de
sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
on commence
kippour
on n'a que les contres qui s'abstient il
est adopté le 157 double avis
défavorable qui est pour
et contre ils savent si elle n'est pas
adoptée le 47 rectifié bis double avis
défavorable qui est pour
et qui est contre
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 203 de
la commission avec un avis sagesse du
gouvernement qu'est pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient est adoptée 259 un double
avis défavorable qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il ne pas adopter
le 26 double avis défavorable qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il ne pas
adopter le 125 double avis défavorable
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté le 50 rectifié
quater w pardon
aux mais je vous en prie monsieur chasse
1 vous pouvez la faire
rétrospectivement
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'ai voulu simplement dire dans le 125e
actuellement nous avons des personnes
vaccinées mais qui malheureusement s'est
rendu compte que elle pouvait être
contagieuse alors qu'avant au monde au
moment où on adopter le pass vaccinale
on pensait que ces personnes n'étaient
pas contagieuse donc j'ai simplement
voulu dire que le losc eux on gère une
maison de retraite avec un directeur
avec des soignants eh bien on est
angoissé d'avoir un cluster j'ai
simplement voulu dire que pendant
quelques temps il serait bon
qu' on puisse avoir un test
avant c'est à dire 24 heures avant de se
rendre à vis rendre visite à ses parents
même si on a le pass d'accident c'est
tout je ne suis pas contre les visites à
maison de retraite pas du tout je suis
je suis pour qu'il y ait une sécurité et
je suis pour qu'il y ait ce contrôle 24
heures avant même s'il y a un pad
vaccinale parce que les gens vaccinés
peuvent être contagieux le sont moins
mais ils peuvent l'être
merci nous en étions donc aux 50
rectifié quater qui est un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 121 double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
170 rectifié bis double avis défavorable
c'est pour quelqu'un demande de parole
monsieur chaize
présidente je voudrais donc apporter
quelques compléments aux rapporteurs au
juste ces explications notamment sur le
fait que si effectivement les photos
sont des données personnelles au regard
du rgp des les solutions qui seraient
envisagées peuvent garantir par une raie
une réalisation sécurisé mais aussi par
le nom stockage
ce qui fait que l'on n'aurait pas de
métadonnées et donc pas de problèmes
liés aux aspects des sur la mise en
oeuvre et vicky effectivement j'entends
sauf que il faut bien commencer un jour
parce qu'on sera à chaque fois les
éléments et on ne pourra jamais faire
évoluer donc le système et enfin gère
quelque part enfin pensez aussi à ce que
l'on n'en rajoute pas sur les
inconvénients notamment au niveau des
cafetiers ou des organisateurs et je
souhaiterais par cet amendement faire en
sorte qu on ennuie pas tous ces gens là
m'ont dit coordination je suis là
merci je veux pas de prédication de vote
jamais donc on voit le soixante dix
rectifié bis avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui compte qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le groupe d'amendements
identiques
suivant à partir du 80 tombe du fait de
l'adoption du 203 de la commission nous
passons donc aux 173 double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui comptent qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté on le sent 77 double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée sur
le bloc d'amendements identiques je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
du groupe socialiste avant nous
procédions scrutin je vais donner la
parole à une série no
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous sommes à une heure avancée
moi j'ai voté le pass sanitaires et je
vais voter le pass vaccinale mais en
même temps j'ai deux inquiétudes
la question de la sortie
et puis la question du contrôle
alors sur la sortie je pense qu'on aura
d'autres occasions pour en discuter mais
sur cette question du contrôle faut-il
renforcer le contrôle moi
personnellement je vous avoue que je
n'en suis pas sûre faut-il inciter les
bars et restaurants ont leur permettre
de renforcer ce contrôle d'identité
j'ai l'impression d'ailleurs qu' ils ne
sont pas très nombreux à le souhaiter où
elle demandé parce qu'ils sont très
conscients de la difficulté de la mise
en oeuvre et puis surtout il me semble
mais ça a été dit dans la présentation
de ces amendements par mes collègues ça
a été dit par loïc hervé parent par le
sénateur kahn fait ça a été dit par le
sénateur bonnecarrère dans l'explication
de la discussion générale je pense que
nous avons un vrai risque de basculer
dans une autre société
dans le
avec le danger de jeu normes donc je
suis le vertige de la norme le vertige
de contrôle et je pense que même si nous
sommes en pandémie nous devons être
vigilants par rapport à ce vertige qui
existe toujours pour un pouvoir exécutif
et je vais vous dire j'ai un peu plus
loin encore je préfère même que quelques
personnes puissent se glisser avec des
passes
sanitaires ou dépassent ou impasse
vaccinale un certain que de prendre le
risque de basculer dans une société
qu'on a du mal à imaginer qui m'apparaît
dangereuse voilà la raison pour laquelle
je voterai ces amendements je vous
remercie
et il d'autres explications de vote
avant que nous procédions au scrutin
public
donc je vous rappelle que sur ces
amendements dont je vous redonne les
numéros 7 rectifié bis 17 19 51 58 71 80
à 100
464 et 168 l'avis de la commission est
un avis de sagesse et l'avis du
gouvernement un avis défavorable qui va
être procédé au scrutin
et publicis ont tous un peu vide
il
t'es bon
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà autant en direct en salle des
conférences je me trouve juste à côté de
la musique puisque air en ce moment un
scrutin public sur une dizaine
d'amendements qui vise à supprimer la
possibilité de renforcer les contrôles
des passes vaccinaux comme avec les
cafetiers ou les restaurateurs qui
pourraient ainsi vérifier la concordance
entre votre pass vaccinale et vos
documents d'identité on a entendu de
nombreux sénateurs notamment sur les
bancs de la gauche de la droite les
écologistes mais aussi un dans d'autres
dans d'autres groupes politiques
s'opposer à cette nouvelle possibilité
de contrôler le ps vaccinale et
retournement de situation lors de
l'examen de ces amendements il ya
quelques instants on a entendu le
rapporteur et l'ère philippe bas et bien
qu'ils aient donné à sagesse donc qu'il
ne dit pas pour ou contre les sénateurs
vont pouvoir voter comme cela pour ou
contre sans consignes de vote de la
commission des lois et donc on va
pouvoir écouter tout de suite le
résultat on 3,37 le sénat a donc adopté
l'adoption de ces amendements fait
tomber les deux amendements suivant que
nous n'avons donc pas de raison de se
soumettre au vote
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance nous avons examiné 75 amendement
cours de la journée il en reste 100 cat
a examiné la prochaine séance aura lieu
demain à doha lieu aujourd'hui mercredi
12 janvier à 15 heures pour les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
la science et de v
[Musique]
voilà vous l'avez suivi toute la soirée
sur l'antenne de public sénat en direct
avec notamment cette série de quarante
trois amendements qui étaient examinés
tous ensemble sur le fonctionnement de
ce pass vaccinale tels que le sénat
souhaiteraient le voir adopté et on le
voit les la liste des différences entre
le texte de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat se rallongent notamment sur la
possibilité pour des tiers pour des
particuliers inquiets qui sont des
professionnels de contrôler un pass
vaccinale est donc et bien la séance est
élevé reprise demain après les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement il y aura
ensuite un donc la suite de ce texte qui
va être fini d'être examinée demain
ensuite il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire entre députés et sénateurs
pour essayer de trouver un compromis
c'est la fin de cette émission prochain
rendez vous avec l'info 17h30 demain
matin avec l'émission dorian mancini
très bonne si des programmes soient
chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]